İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar.
11 Şubat değil 12 Şubat 2025 çarşamba günü hemen düzeltiyoruz.
Saat 19.31 63. ders günümüz.
Dersimize başlıyoruz.
Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz.
Ses ve görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Yiğit Bey'in bir sorusu var hemen okuyalım.
Hocam derse başlamadan bir soru sormak istiyorum.
En son yaptığımız Singleton örneğinde iki if deyimli Mutex kullanmak ile
Colvance arasındaki maliyet farkı için ne söyleyebiliriz?
Doğruysa isterseniz şimdi kodu hatırlamıyorum.
Ama şöyle diyelim en azından.
Arkadaşlar zaten Vance Flag ve Colvance bu iş için oluşturulmuş araçlar.
Yani bir kodun sadece bir kere çalıştırılması.
Bu da tipik olarak değişkenlerin predsafe olarak initialize edilmesine yönelik.
Dolayısıyla zaten amacı bu olduğu için derleyicilerin implementasyonunda olabilecek en yüksek efficiency ile oluşturulmuş olmalı.
Ama hangi kodla karşılaştırmamız gerektiğini anlayamadığım için daha sonra bakmak üzere soruya şimdilik bu kadar cevap vereyim.
Arkadaşlar şimdi tam cevap veremedim ama tekrar gerekirse döneriz.
Yani böyle durumlarda ben hiç düşünmeden arkadaşlar bir darboğazı olur mu olmaz mı diye düşünmeden herkes gibi Vance Flag ve Colvance'ı kullanıyorum.
Şimdi bir de şöyle bir şey var.
Eğer Vance Flag ve Colvance'ı kullanmadan diyelim ki siz predsafe initialization yapayım derken yanlış bir kod yazabilirsiniz.
O try safe olmayabilir ama Colvance'da böyle bir hata yapma riski yok ya da varsa da çok çok az.
Arkadaşlar şimdi bugünkü derste Mutexler ve Lag sınıfları üstünde konuşmaya devam edeceğiz.
Yani bugün maalesef bu konu anca biter.
Ondan sonra da eğer vaktimiz kalırsa bugünkü derste vaktimiz kalmazsa bir dahaki derste şu Condition Variable konusunu göreceğiz.
Yani bu Türkçe'ye doğrudan çevirirsek koşul değişkeni Condition Variable.
Arkadaşlar senkronizasyon genelde birden fazla trade'in birlikte çalışması durumunda bunların birbirleriyle ilişkisini trade safe olarak sağlamaya yönelik araçların hepsine deniyor.
Mesela senkronizasyon derken buna neler dahil ortak paylaşımlı veriye trade safe olarak erişim yani tanımsız davranış olmadan bir trade'in bir veriyi hazırlaması ama başka bir trade'in bu veriyi kullanması efendim trade'ler arasındaki böyle veri alışverişi bunların hepsi arkadaşlar senkronizasyon gerektiriyor.
Ama senkronizasyon için daha önce de söyledik farklı farklı araçlar var.
Yani örneğin atomik değişkenleri kullanmak bir araç olabilir.
Mutex kullanmak ya da mutexleri sarmalayan lag ray sınıflarını kullanmak ya da duruma göre bir Condition Variable kullanmak arkadaşlar farklı farklı çözümler olabilir.
Ya da bunların içlerini kullanmadan buradan yüksek seviyeli bir kütüphane kullanabilirsiniz.
Yani kütüphane bunu kendisi halleder.
Sizin senkronizasyonla uğraşmanıza gerek kalmaz öyle kütüphaneler de var.
Ama şimdi öncelikle şunun çok iyi anlaşılması gerekiyor.
Arkadaşlar bir fonksiyonun örneğin single trade çalışmasıyla multi trade çalışmasının arasında ciddi farklılıklar var.
Neden?
Şimdi bir fonksiyonun kodu derleyici herhangi bir şekilde orada ilave bir kod görmezse ki daha sonraki konularımız derleyici her zaman arkadaşlar programın gözlenebilir davranışının değişmeyeceğine güvenerek optimizasyon yapıyor.
Ve bu durumda senkronizasyonla ilgili bir zorlayıcı neden yoksa derleyici single trade olarak çalıştığını düşünüyor.
Mesela bakın çok basit örneklerle başlayalım.
Şöyle bir fonksiyonumuz olsun.
Evet.
Ben sadece size bir fonksiyon göstereceğim.
Mesela ismi
bu olsun arkadaşlar
ve
parametresi
diyelim ki bir vektör olsun.
Mesela burada şöyle bir kod olduğunu düşünelim.
if
vekempty
değilse
artık bunları biliyoruz.
SDR konusunu gördük.
Yani vektör boş değilse en az bir elemana sahipse
programcı da
burada vektördeki ilk elemanı
kullanacak bir kod yazsın.
Kullanacak derken herhangi bir şey olabilir.
Mesela değerini yazdırmak olabilir.
Ya da değerini
bir fonksiyona göndermek olabilir.
Önemli olan burada kullanılması.
Arkadaşlar şimdi
single trade çalıştığı zaman
burada hiçbir problem yok.
Vektör
boş değilse
if'in doğru kısmına girecek
ve if'in doğru kısmında
vektördeki ilk öye
erişmiş olacağım.
ama şimdi bu fonksiyon
birden fazla
thread tarafından
çalıştırılıyorsa
ya da şöyle diyelim
bu fonksiyon birden fazla
thread tarafından
çalıştırılıyor demeyelim de
birden fazla
thread çalışıyorsa
ve birden fazla
thread
aynı vektörü
kullanıyorsa
şimdi durumlar
yiğit tamamen
farklı değil mi?
Çünkü bakın
şu kod yürütüldüğünde
empty fonksiyonu
false değer verebilir.
fakat
programın akışı
bu deyime gelmeden
arkadaşlar
vektöre
bir eleman
eklenmiş olabilir.
Başka bir threadle
bir vektöre
eleman eklemiş olabilir.
Pardon
eleman silmiş olabilir.
Düşünsenize
o zaman
vektör boş değil
diye buraya gelecek
fakat
bu işlemler
kesiksiz yapılmıyor ki
yani bununla
bununla arasına
hiçbir işlem
girmeyecek
diye bir garanti yok ki
işte burada
İngilizce kullanılan
bir terim var
bundan sonra da
bazı derslerle
kullanacağım
interleaved olabilir
yani aralara başka
işlem girebilir.
O zaman
tamamen
programma
mantığı
yanlış olur
değil mi?
Burada da
boş değil
diye giriyor
ama buraya geldiğinde
boşalıyor.
Mesela bu
single thread
olsaydı
herhangi bir şekilde
full fonksiyonun
çağrılmasında
bir engel
ya da
lojik bir problem
olmayacaktı.
Ya da şöyle bir koda
bakın
mesela çok sık yapılan
hatalardan biri
izleyin
başka bir örnek
bir tane değişkenimiz olsun
global değişken
mesela bu
global değişkenin
değeri
ne olsun
ya da
bir tane
başka değişkenim var
ready play
bu da
host değerdi
şimdi
full fonksiyonu
global değişkeni
set ediyor
mesela
ondan sonra
bu bayrak değişkeni
pro
değeri çekiyor
yine bar fonksiyonu var
ve bar fonksiyonu
bir döngü
deyimi
kullanmış
ready flag
sol solduğu sürece
arkadaşlar
dönen bir döngü
şimdi programcının
mantığı şu
buradan çıktıktan sonra
da diyelim ki
geval değişkeninin
değerini bir şekilde
kullanmış
şimdi bakınız
bu iki fonksiyonun
farklı
threadler tarafından
birlikte çalıştırılması
durumunda
burayı çok
dikkatli izlememiz
gerekiyor
bir
thread safety
thread güvenliği
garantisi var mı
yani
şöyle olabilir mi
ee bu da bu koşuyor
ne zaman ki bu
ready flag'i
true yapacak
o zaman
arkadaşlar
burada
döngüden çıkacak
döngüden çıktıktan sonra da
geval'in
değişmiş değerini
kullanacağız
yani şöyle bir koddan
bahsediyorum
örneğin
stud
thread
başlık dosyası
dahil edilmiş mi
evet
stud thread
ya da
j thread
arkadaşlar
sanki bu kod
doğru gibi görünse de
bu kod tamamen
yanlış
neden yanlış
bakınız
bu arada yanlış bir şey
de anlaşılmasın
mesela şöyle derseniz
Necati
sen yanlış demiştin
al sana
geval
tekrar çalıştırıyorum
şimdi benim
debug edip bunu gözlememin
hiçbir şekilde
bir garantisi yok
arkadaşlar
derleyici
kodlarda
observable behavior
değişmediği sürece
istediği gibi
optimizasyon yapabilir
değil mi
kodu
farklı şekilde
yazılmış olabilir
yazılmış gibi
ele alana
söyleyemedim
ben
sinirlendim
derleyici
observable behavior
gözlenebilir
davranış değişmediği sürece
kodu
farklı biçimde
yazılmış gibi
ele alıp
ona göre
derleyebilir
as if
105.
kere
söyledik
işte burada
tipik
optimizasyonlardan
biri de
ingilizce
reordering
dediğimiz durum
yani
yeniden
sıralama
arkadaşlar
şimdi derleyici
burada
işlem sayısını
azaltmak için
duruma göre
observable behavior
değişmediği için
bakın bu
fonksiyon açısından
değişir mi
ha geval önce
olmuş
ha da
ready flag
arkadaşlar
önce
true olmuş
herhangi bir şekilde
derleyici
açısından
burada
derleyicinin
kestiriminde
gözlenebilir
davranışın
değişmeyeceği
açık
işte mesela
böyle bir
reordering
olduğunda
arkadaşlar
tamamen
durum değişebilir
değil mi
yani örneğin
burada
ready flag
true olduğu için
bu threadte
döngüden çıkıp
ondan sonra
geval değişkenliğinin
değerini
değişmiş değeri
olarak değil de
10 değeri
olarak kullanabilir
ama sadece
compiler tarafında
optimizasyon yok
işlemci tarafında da
bir sürü
optimizasyon var
örneğin
branch prediction
arkadaşlar
prefatching
vesaire
hepsine
şimdi girmek
istemiyorum
farklı farklı
optimizasyonlar var
art arkada
inşallah
bir derste de
bu atomik
konusuna falan
geldiğimizde
görürüz
bir de bu
keşlerin
o
ön bellek
mekanizmalarının
yönetilmesi var
Yiğitince
diyor ki
hocam
fonksiyon tanımları
aynı dosyada
olsa da
önemsemiyor mu
önemsemiyor
derleyici için
fonksiyon
ayrı bir
birim
derleyici
bunların
farklı
threadlerden
çalıştırılacağını
çalıştırabileceğini
göz önüne
almak zorunda
değil ki
ama işte
öyle dinsel
mekanizmalar
var ki
buraya dikkat
ilerleyen derslerde
oradaki terminolojiyi
standartların
kullandığı
terminolojiyi
göreceğiz
bakın şimdi
C++'da
modern C++
standartı
Yiğit
öyle durumlar
var ki
bu durumu
İngilizce'de
happened
before
terimiyle
tanımlıyor
happened
before
tam birebir
çevirirsek
önce oldu
bu
şundan
önce oldu
ya da bu
şundan
önce olmak
zorunda
işte belirli
garantiler
sağlandığında
farklı
threadler
koysa
dahi
siz
bir threadin
bakın bakın
bellek
üstünde
oluşturduğu
oluşturması
gereken
değişiklikleri
örneğin
bir değerin
bir değişkenin
değerin
değişmesi gibi
başka bir
threadle
belirli bir
noktaya
geldiğinde
o değişikliklerin
artık
diğer thread
tarafından
görülebilir
garantisinde
olmasını
sağlayacak
araçlar var
işte bunu
standart
bazı özel
terimlerle
açıklıyor
şimdi oraya
girmek
istemiyorum
ama
en azından
biraz
konuşmuş
ya da
oraya
gönderme
yapmış
olalım
diye
söylüyorum
işte
burada
yine
standartın
kullandığı
bir terim var
synchronized
width
yani bir şeyle
senkronize
olmak
eğer
standart
bir
thread'deki
örneğin
bir kodun
başka bir
thread'deki
bir kodla
senkronize
olduğunu
söylüyorsa
işte
burada
o thread'de
en son
yapılan
işlemin
diğer
thread'de
yapılacak
işlemden
önce
etkilerinin
görülebilir
olma
garantisi
var
diyor
evet burası
biraz karmaşık
ama inşallah
oraya kadar
ilerleyeceğiz
ama şimdi
sadece şunu
söylemek
istedim
işin içine
multi
thread
programlama
girdiği
zaman
artık
koda
bakış açımız
şimdiye
kadar
yazdığımız
kodlardaki
gibi
değil
eğer
tek
bir
thread
çalıştıracaksa
bir problem
yok
ama
birden fazla
thread varsa
thread safety
sağlamak için
birçok noktayı
göz önüne
almamız
gerekiyor
ve
birçok yerde
ister istemez
senkronizasyon
mekanizmalarından
birini
kullanmamız
gerekiyor
şimdi bu
mutex ve
lock
sınıflarına
yani mutexleri
sarmalayan
sınıflara
geri döneceğiz
önce oradaki
eksikleri
tamamlayacağız
ama
tekrar
şurayı bir
arkadaşlar
hatırlatmak
istiyorum
şuraya
kopyalayayım
bizim
mutex
sınıflarımız
vardı
stud mutex
stud time
mutex
recursive
time
mutex
shared
ve shared
time
mutex
bir de
özellikle
bir exception
gönderildiğinde
bir
mutexin
kilikli durumda
kalmaması
için
ve
bir takım
hataların
yapılmasını
zorlaştırmak
için
bu mutex
sınıflarını
sarmalayan
mutex
nesnelerini
sarmalayan
tipik olarak
destroy
olduklarında
eğer
mutex
halen
kilitli
durumdaysa
mutex'i
unlock
fonksiyonuna
çağırarak
onları
kilidi serbest
bırakan
ray sınıfları
vardı
işte
şimdi
bu
sınıfların
interfeyslerin
biraz daha
detaylı
göreceğiz
biraz daha
fazla örnek
yapacağız
arkadaşlar
ben
şöyle de bir
belki çok detaylı
olmasa da
arkadaşlar
bir
slide hazırladım
diyeyim
biraz zamanı
oynamak için
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakınız
şimdi biraz karmaşık
gideceğim
ama
sonuçta
yine
kaldığımız yere
geri döneceğiz
şimdi bu
deadlock
konusu
özellikle önemli
ve
data race
konusu
yani iki tane
önemli alt başlık
biraz bahsettik
biri deadlock
biri
arkadaşlar
data race
şimdi data race
zaten tanımsız
davranış
deadlock da sonuçta
tanımsız davranış
ama tipik görüntüsü
böyle olmak zorunda
değil
ama tipik görüntüsü
threadlerin
bloke olarak
ilerleyememesi
ondan da bahsetmiştik
bunun en tipik
nedeni
birden fazla
mutex'in
kullanılması
ve bu durumda
bir thread
bir mutex'in
kilidinin açılmasını
beklerken
diğer
bir thread de
diğer mutex'in
kilidinin açılmasını
bekliyor
ama
kilidinin açılması
için de
bunların
ilerlemesi
gerekiyor
bu nedenle
ikisi
ya da daha fazlası
bu döke oluyor
ama şu
data race
konusuna
geldiğimiz zaman
data race
tanımsız
davranış
dedik de
orada
arka planda
neler oluyor
biraz da
ona bakalım
mesela en tipik
problemlerden biri
İngilizce'de
torn right
deniyor
buradaki
torn biliyorsunuz
tear
fiilinin
participalı
arkadaşlar
şimdi
işlemcilerde
birçok işlem
birden fazla
aşamada
yapılıyor
yani
bir işlem
ondan sonra
bir daha işlem
ve
multi thread
programlamada
bu iki
diyelim ki
instruction
arasına
bir başka
işlem
girebiliyor
işte bakın
mesela bir değişkenin
değerinin
değişmesi
siz şimdi
şöyle düşünebilirsiniz
bir thread
geliyor
bir değişkenin
değerini
değiştiriyor
diğer thread
ya o değişkenin
değerinin
değişmeden
önceki
durumunu
gözleyecek
ya da
değiştikten
sonraki
hayır
böyle bir
garanti yok
garanti olması
için
senkronizasyon
yapılmış olması
gerekiyor
eğer böyle
bir garanti
yoksa
farklı farklı
problemler
olabilir
mesela bakın
çok tipik
bir örnek
vermiş
burada
diyor ki
a ve b
threadleri
bir
memory
location'a
yazmak
istiyorlar
a'nın
yazmak
istediği
değer
hexadismal
olarak
0x1234
ama
b'nin de
yazmak
istediği
değer
şimdi burada
torn
right'ın
ne demek
olduğunu
açıklıyor
arkadaşlar
böyle ki
a thread'i
önce buraya
0x12
yazıyor
öyle olabilir
gerçekten
arkadaşlar
yani
bu
2 byte'lık
verinin
1 byte'ını
yazmış
fakat o zaman
b thread'i
araya giriyor
ve o
4567'yi
yazıyor
takip edebiliyor
musunuz
sonra
a thread'i
yazma işlemine
devam ediyor
diğer parçayı
da yazıyor
bakın
3 4
ama bu durumda
ne oldu
bu iki
thread'i
çalıştıktan sonra
bu işlemi
yaptıktan sonra
bizim
değişkenimizin
değeri
arkadaşlar
ne
1 2 3 4
hexadismal
olarak
ne de
efendim
4567 oldu
4534 oldu
ya böyle bir
hata tipi
var mı
var
gerçekten de
işte bu
turnwrite
dediğimiz
biçimde
bir
data race
sonuçlanabilir
ve bunu
debug ederken
yakalama şansımız da
çok yüksek değil
şimdi
diğer taraftan
data race
her zaman
problem
şu deadlock
konusuna
biraz
geri dönersek
arkadaşlar
bir kere
birbiriyle
karıştırılan
iki tane
ayrı problem
var
birine
İngilizce'de
deadlock
deniyor
diğerine
İngilizce'de
livelock
deniyor
şimdi
ikisi
aynı şeymiş
gibi
görünse de
arada
ciddi bir
fark var
nedir bu
ciddi fark
arkadaşlar
hocam
deterministik
olmaması
sırf
optimizasyondan
mı
hayır
sırf
optimizasyondan
değil
tabii ki
arkadaşlar
hangi
thread'in
o kodda
nerede
olduğu
bir t
zamanında
herhangi
bir şekilde
belli
değil
evet
şimdi
deadlock
aslında ne demek
iki ya da
daha fazla
thread var
birbirlerinin
sahip olduğu
kaynakları
beklerken
bloki oluyorlar
ikisi de
bloki olduğu için
hiçbir ilerleme
kaydedilemiyor
biri
diğerinin
kaynağı
serbest bırakmasını
örneğin kilidi
açmasını
bekliyor
diğeri de
diğer kilidi
açmasını
bekliyor
örnek kod
yazmıştık
ama
livelock'da
durum daha
farklı
arkadaşlar
livelock'da
türkçeye de
canlı kilit
diye
çeviriyorlar
bakın burada
da şöyle
güzel bir
tanım verdim
burada
threadler
bloki
olmuyor
ama
iki thread de
ilerliyor
ama
sürekli
arkadaşlar
birbiriyle
çatışan
yani birbiriyle
çelişen
işlemler
gerçekleştirdiğinden
ilerleme
kaydedilmiyor
yani
ilerleme
kaydedilmemesinin
nedeni
threadlerin
bloke olması
değil
threadlerin
birbirleriyle
ilgili
çelişen
işlemler
yapması
basit bir örnek
vereceğim
birazdan
arkadaşlar
evet
şimdi
mesela
şöyle bir
analoji yapmış
güzel bir
analoji
diyor ki
iki tane
kibar
nazik
insanın
bir araya
geldiğini
düşünün
bunlar
dar bir kapıdan
geçecekler
bizde de vardır ya
biri diyor ki
önden buyur
diğeri de diyor ki
siz buyurun
ikisi de kabul etme
önden buyur
yok üstadım
sen buyur
böyle
ama bloke olmuş
durumda değiller
ikisi de birbirlerine
sürekli
yol vermeye
çalışıyor
mesela bu
gerçekten
bir
live lag
ya da ben şöyle
bir espri yapıyorum
Türklerin
hesap ödeme
hali
hesap ödecek
aman ben ödeyeceğim
aman sen ödeyeceğim
biri diyor ki
dünyada olmaz
sen benim
misafirim
öbürü de diyor ki
hayır hayır olur mu
bu arada
ikisi de hesabı
ödeyemiyor
işte burada
live lag
oluşuyor
arkadaşlar
mesela şöyle
temsili bir
senaryo oluşturdum
burada
kodun ne kadar
gerçekçi olduğundan
ziyade
live lag
olması
önemli
izleyin
şimdi
kodun tamamını
anlamamız
gerekmiyor
ama
eğer
daha sonra
kitabı da
koyacağım
üstünden
geçerseniz
neden
live lag
olduğunu
daha iyi
anlayabileceksiniz
çok da
karmışık bir
kod değil
arkadaşlar
buradaki
counter
değişkeni
bizim henüz
görmediğimiz
bir konuya
ilişkin
bu değişken
atomik
bir değişken
değişken
ne demek
işte
şöyle demiştim
değil mi
mesela
bir değişkenin
değerinin
değişmesi
tek bir
işlemde
olmak zorunda
değil
mesela
birden
fıkhı
bir değişkenin
değerinin
bir arttırıldığını
düşünün
yani o
değişkenin
değeri
doğrudan
onken
on bir
olmuyor
eğer böyle
bir garanti
olsaydı
şuna
güvenebilirdik
redler
bu değişkenleri
kullanırken
ya değerinin
artmadan
önceki
halini
kullanacak
on değerini
ya da
değeri artık
artmış
olduktan
sonra
on bir
değeriyle
kullanacak
yani
atomik bir
operasyon
şu demek
operasyonun
başlamasıyla
bitmesi
arasına
başka bir
thread
girme
ihtimali
yok
burası
çok önemli
atomik
operation
öyle bir
operasyon ki
o
operation
başlamasıyla
bitmesi
arasına
ikinci bir
threadin
girme
ihtimali
yok
bu da
ne demek
atomik
değişkenler
üstünde
yapılan
atomik
işlemler
o
değişkeni
kullanan
kodlar
o kodları
çalıştıran
threadlerde
ya
önceki
de
ya
değişmeden
önceki
değer
ya da
değiştikten
sonraki
değeri
görecek
burayı
anladık
mı
yani
en azından
bir
data
race
olma
ihtimali
yok
zaten
data
race
konusunda
da
şunu
söylemiştim
data
race
engellemenin
birden fazla
yolu
var
işte
birden fazla
yoldan
biri de
değişkenleri
atomik yapmak
atomik değişken
kullanırsanız
arkadaşlar
orada
data
race
olma
ihtimali
yok
dejanti
data
race
olma
ihtimali
yok
derken
yine
bir
thread
yazma
amaçlı
en az
olsa
dahi
yine
data
race
olmayacak
mı
şimdi biz
konumuza
geri dönelim
arkadaşlar
bakınız
burada
full
fonksiyonu
içinde
sürekli
dönen bir
döngü
var
bu
döngünün
her turunda
bir
log
kart
nesnesi
oluşturulmuş
bu ne demek
log kart
nesnesi
mutex'e
edinecek
log kartı
görmüştük
rayı sınıfı
yani programın
akışı
bu noktaya
geldiğinde
artık
kilit
edinilmiş
durumda
yani bu
if deyimi
mutex
kilitliyken
yürütecek
diyor ki
eğer
counter
mod 2
0'sa
yani counter
çift sayıysa
counter'ı
arttırıyor
ve arkadaşlar
counter'ın
artması da
demek
1 artması da
counter'ın
tek sayı
haline gelmesi
demek
ama counter
çift sayı
değilse
if'in
else kısmına
girecek
false
pet'e
girecek
burada da
standart
output'a
waiting
yazısı
bekliyor
çıkartacak
bar fonksiyonunda
da yine
benzer şekle
böyle bir
sonsuz döngü
var
orada da
bir mutex
kullanılmış
ve mutex
aynı mutex
de kilitleme
yapılmış
lockguard
nesnesiyle
bu arada
birini böyle yazdım
şunu göstermek
için
burada
tabi ki
aslında lockguard
birazdan yine
o konuya
döneceğiz
bu bir
arkadaşlar
generic sınıf
ama template
argümanını
yazmamam
ne ve ne
c++
standartıyla
gelen
sitat
ben böyle yerlerde
artık sitatı
mutlaka kullanıyorum
çünkü o
sürekli her yerde
açısal parantez olması
biraz
görüntü kirliliği
de oluşturuyor
arkadaşlar
bu da tam tersi
counter
tek sayısa
counter arttırıyor
aksi halde
waiting
diyor
şimdi bakın
programı
çalıştırdığım zaman
runtime'da
ilginç bir durum
göreceksiniz
arkadaşlar görüyorsunuz
değil mi
bir bloke olma
durumu var mı
bloke olma
durumu yok
ama
ikisi de
ilerleme
kaydedemiyor
yani ilerleme
kaydetse
mesela ne olacak
counter'ın
artmış değerini
yazdırması lazım
arkadaşlar
o belki çok
nadir oluyor
ama
sürekli
daha çok
görüyorsunuz
burada
waiting
yazısı çıkıyor
örnekleri
çoğaltmak mümkün
burada önemli olan
live lock
arkadaşlar
dead lock
farklı şeyler
çok daha sık
karşılaşılan
bir senaryo
threadlerin
bloke olması
ama live lock
o kadar sık
olmasa da
o da
önemli bir
senaryo
kesinlikle
şimdi biz kaldığımız yere
geri dönelim
arkadaşlar
bakın
okuma tarafında da
yine aynı şekilde
bu
horn read
olabilir
yani örneğin
bir thread
bir değişkenin
değerini
bir memory
location'dan
değer çekecek
önce birinci
yarıyı çekiyor
ama o arada
araya başka
bir operasyon
giriyor
alması gereken
değer yerine
bambaşka bir
değer çekebiliyor
bu
son konulara
geldiğimiz zaman
arkadaşlar
işte bu
son konular
derken
atomik değişkenler
atomik operasyonlar
bunların
önemini
biraz daha iyi
göreceğiz
hocam bu örnekte
neden öyle olduğunu
açıklayabildiniz mi
açıkladınız mı
yok açıklamadım
sadece bir örnek
vermek istedim
çünkü oraya
girmek istemiyorum
ama
ben
kodu da
bitaba koyacağım
hani onun üstünde
düşünmeyi
size bırakacağım
burada önemli olan
sadece neye
değinmek istedim
deadlock'la
livelock
farklı şeyler
arasındaki fark
biri
blokü olma
nedeniyle
threadler ilerleyemiyor
ama diğerinde
arkadaşlar
blokü
olmamalarına
rağmen
threadler
arasındaki
birbiriyle
çelişen
işlemler
söz konusu
olduğu için
ilerleme
kaydedilemiyor
şimdi biz
tekrar
arkadaşlar
şu
mutex ve
lag sınıflarına
geri dönelim
burada
daha
epey bir
konuşmamız
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakın
burada
shared
mutex'ler hariç
onlar zaten
daha sonra
eklendi
bu mutex'lerin
operasyonlarını
görüyorsunuz
yostis'in kitabından
ama durumu
çok güzel gösteren
bir örnek
şimdi
bir tablo
örnek diyorum
bakın şimdi
burada
neyi
özellikle
anlamamız
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
mutex
en basit
mutex sınıfı
onun
lag fonksiyonu var
try lag fonksiyonu var
unlock fonksiyonu var
arkadaşlar
birden fazla
kilidi
kez
mutex'i birden fazla
kilitleyemiyor
recursive
mutex'de
arkadaşlar
şu grup
bakın
evet
mutex'i
lag fonksiyonu ile
ediniyorum
bu arada
try lag
hepsinde var
unlock
ama
try lag
for ve
until
olması için
yani
geçen dersimizde
görmüştük
belirli bir süre
kilidi edinmeye
çalışmak
ya da
belirli bir
time point'e kadar
kilidi edinmeye
çalışması
için
ya
timed mutex
ya da
recursive
timed mutex
olması gerekiyor
recursive
mutex'in
özelliği
birden fazla
kez
kilitlenebilir
olması
işte ne
demiştik
eğer
bizim istediğimiz
minimal
bir
interfejse
o bize yetiyorsa
mutex'i
kullanalım
ama
birden fazla
kilitleme
gerekiyorsa
mecbur
recursive
mutex
kullanacağız
efendim
belirli bir
süreye ilişkin
kilitlemeye
çalışsın
istiyorsanız
time
mutex
olması
gerekiyor
ama
hem birden fazla
kez kilitlensin
hem de
efendim
birerli bir
süre boyunca
kilidi edinmeye
çalışsın
istiyorsanız
yani
interfesteki
bu
trialog for
trialog
anti
fonksiyonlarını
çağırmak
istiyorsanız
o zaman
recursive
time
mutex
kullanmanız
gerekiyor
şimdi yalnız
burada
arkadaşlar
mutex sınıfının
bir
fonksiyonu
daha var
yani bu
buradaki
fonksiyonlar
dışında
şimdi
bir fonksiyon
daha var
dedim de
ama önce
nereye gelelim
şuraya da
bakalım bir
izleyin
hızlı bir
şekilde
bir fonksiyonu
daha var
bu da
arkadaşlar
native
handle
fonksiyonu
native handle
hemen hemen
concurrency
kütüphanesindeki
bütün sınıflarda
var
native handle
gördüğünüz zaman
arkadaşlar
bu tipik olarak
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri oluyor
native handle
ve handle
veriyor
bu handle
vasıtasıyla
bu konuda
işletim sisteminin
apisini
sistem fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
geçenlerde
bir örnek
yapmıştık
örneğin
thread'in
prioritiesini
doğrudan
bizim kütüphane
c++
standart
kütüphanesiyle
değiştirme
şansımız yok
ama
native handle
handle
alıp
yani
native handle
fonksiyonunu
çağırıp
yine o
nested type
olan
native handle
type
türünden
handle
alıp
onu
doğrudan
örneğin
windows'un
apisine
argüman olarak
ne yapmıştık
geçmiştik
arkadaşlar
evet
şimdi
mutexlerin
aslında
fonksiyonları
şunlar
ekranda gördünüz
ama bakın
altına dikkat edin
if available
yani bütün
mutexlerle
olmak zorunda
değil
hemen
constructor
destructor
değil mi
lock
fonksiyonu
try lock
yani
kilitlemeye
çalışıyor
ve
süre ve
time point
alan
try lock
for try lock
until
fonksiyonları
unlock
fonksiyonu
ve
native handle
fonksiyonu
bunlar
işte buradaki
fonksiyonlar
burada
toplam gördüğümüz
interfesteki
fonksiyonlar
evet
şimdi gelelim
tekrar
bizim bu
ray sınıflarına
ray sınıflarından
amacı neydi
ya ben
mutex'i
doğrudan
kullanırsam
lock
işlemini
yaptıktan sonra
bir exception
throw ederse
exception
yakalanınca
artık onun
unlock
fonksiyonunun
çağrılması
imkansız
o yüzden
diyoruz ki
hayır hayır
biz mutex'leri
doğrudan
hiç neredeyse
kullanmıyoruz
her zaman
mutex'i
sarmalayan
ama
destruktör'ı
yoluyla
mutex'in
efendim
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağıran
bu ray
sınıflarını
kullanıyoruz
neydi bu ray
sınıfları
arkadaşlar
lock
card
unique
lock
scope
ve
shared
lock
şuraya da
demin
listesini
yazmıştık
evet
lock
card
unique
lock
scoped
shared
lock
şimdi bunlara
önce makro
düzeyde tekrar
bakalım
lock
card
minimal
guard
sınıfımız
yani
eğer lock
card işimize
yarıyorsa
o zaman
lock
card
kullanalım
çünkü
her zaman
şöyle bir şey
var C++'da
gerek
mutex sınıfları
için
gerek
mutex'leri
sarmalayan
ray sınıfları
için
eğer daha fazla
yetenek sunuyorsa
capability
aleti
sunuyorsa
daha fazla
maliyeti var
demektir
arkadaşlar
ama şöyle bir şey oldu
bakın bu
scope lock
C++
standardıyla
eklendi
ve
şöyle diyor
standart
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
effectively
replaces
lock
card
yani
eğer
çok sıra dışı
bir durum yoksa
lock
card yerine
scope
lock
kullanmanızın
bir dezavantajı
yok ama
lock
card'ın
yapamadığı
neyi yapıyordu
scope lock
arkadaşlar
soruyu tekrar
soralım
lock
card'ın
yapamadığı
neyi
yapıyordu
yanıt
birden fazla
mutex'i
arkadaşlar
deadlock
olmama
garantisiyle
kilitliyor
yani
global
lock
fonksiyonunu
çağırmadan
ne yapabiliyoruz
scope lock'a
doğrudan
template olan
constructor'ına
mutex'leri
argüman olarak
geçebiliyoruz
üstelik bu mutex'lerin
aynı türden
olması
gerekmiyor
yani
scope lock
türünden
bir sınıf
nesnesi
oluşturmak için
scope lock'ın
constructor'ına
örneğin
bir
timed mutex
normal mutex
bir de
recursive
mutex'i
argüman olarak
geçebiliriz
shared lock'ı
aslında
tamamen
shared mutex'leri
sarmalayan
yani
kullanmak istediğim
shared mutex'se
o zaman
öyle ya da böyle
shared lock'ı
sarmalayıcı
sınıfı olarak
bir yerde
kullanmalıyım
yani
shared lock'ın
üye fonksiyonları
shared mutex'in
üye fonksiyonlarına
map edilmiş
durumda
şimdi
lock card'a
geri dönelim
arkadaşlar lock card'ın
bir ilginç özelliği
daha var
daha önceki derslerde
bahsetmedik
bakınız
öyle senaryolar
var ki
elinizde
bir mutex var
ve
bu mutex
lock fonksiyonları
zaten
çağrılmış
yani
kilidi almış
ama siz
kilidi aldıktan
sonra
yani mutex
kilitliyken
yine bunu
sarmalayan
bir
ray nesnesine
ihtiyacınız var
ama
kilit
edinilmiş
durumda
o zaman işte
şöyle yapıyorsunuz
bakınız
lock card
sınıfı
türünden
nesneyi
oluştururken
konstruktörüne
arkadaşlar
mutex'i
argüman
olarak
geçtiniz
ama böyle
olsa
tanımsız
davranış olur
değil mi
çünkü
bu
konstruktör
zaten
mutex'i
mutex'in
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
ama bakın
ikinci bir
argüman
geçiyorsunuz
adapt lock
şimdi bu
argüman
ne işe yarıyor
yine bu
tipik bir
ingilizcesiyle
tag class
yani aslında
adapt lock
underscore t
diye bir
tür var
bu da o türden
constexpr
bir değişken
böyle değişkenler
niçin kullanılıyor
function overload
resolution'ı
sağlamak için
buradaki
konstruktör
ne yapıyor
yine referans
yoluyla
mutex'i
ediniyor
ama
kilitleme
fonksiyonunu
çağırmıyor
yani siz
lock card'ı
ben
bu mutex'i
edineyim
ve onun
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırayım
yerine
zaten
kilitlenmiş
bir mutex'i
edinip
ama
onu tekrar
kilitlemeden
yine
destruktör
kilitli durumdaysa
lock card
nesnemizin
destruktör'ı
arkadaşlar
ne yapıyoruz
yine bizim
destruktör
lock card'ın
destruktör'ı
kilidi
anla geliyor
mesela
bakınız
tipik olarak
eğer
scott lock
olmasaydı
bakınız
iki tane
mutex var
şimdi ben
lock fonksiyonuna
standart kütüphanenin
lock fonksiyonu
vardı ya
standart kütüphanenin
lock fonksiyonuna
birden fazla
argüman
gönderdiğim zaman
hatırlıyor musunuz
bunlar
gönderdiğim
argümanlar
yine
ray nesneleri
olacak
ve
lock fonksiyonu
arka planda
kullandığı
algoritma ile
thread safe
olarak
bunları ne yapacak
kilitlere
edinecek
ya hepsini edinecek
geç birini edinemeyecek
aynı şekilde
arkadaşlar
böylece
hangi sırayla
kilitlere edinirseniz
edinin
lock ile edindiğiniz zaman
lock
free fonksiyonu ile edindiğiniz zaman
hatırlıyorsunuz
o derse
deadlock riski
olmuyordu
hatta şöyle bir örnek
vermiştik
void
pu
hatırlıyorsunuz
değil mi
iki tane fonksiyon var
void
bar
önce ben
örneği vereyim
ondan sonra
sorunuza cevap
vermeye çalışayım
mesela bu
önce
mtx 1'i
sonra mtx 2'yi kilitlerse
partada kilitleme ters yönde yapılırsa
deadlock oluşacak
onun için
ya aynı sırada
kilitlendiğinden emin olmamız gerekiyor
ya da
arkadaşlar
bunu garanti altına alacak
bir yapı kullanmamız gerekiyor
bunun garanti altına alınması için
iki yol var
biri
lock fonksiyonunu çağırmak
ama bakın
lock fonksiyonu benden
adı üstünde
lock nesnelerini
yani dry nesnelerini istiyor
ve
bu fonksiyon
variadik fonksiyon
şimdi
eğer ben şöyle yazsaydım
lock cards
şu yösenk bildirimde yapalım da
evet
lock cards
arkadaşlar
mtx 1
diyelim ki
lock 1
lock card
lock 2
mpx 2
ama burada zaten
arkadaşlar bu kilitleme işlemi
yapılmış durumda değil mi
ama şimdi
şöyle yazarsak
izleyin
bunlar zaten
kilitliyse
o zaman
bunları
kilitli durumda olan
mutex de alırken
eğer mtx ve
mtx 2
kilitliyse
buraya doğrudan
lock card nesnesini
oluştururken
ne verme şansımız var
adopt
lock
verme
şansımız var
unique lock fonksiyonunu
unique lock sınıfını
görürken de
orada
başka argüman olan
tek sınıfları da göreceğiz
ama
onlar lock card'ta yok
mesela bazen de şunu yapmanız
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
bizim
rapper
rapper'ımız
rayi
sınıf nesnemiz
kilidi edinsin
fakat
kilitlemesin
daha sonra
sınıfın
kendi lock fonksiyonuyla
kilitleme yapılsın
mesela lock card
bunu sağlamıyor
ama
birazdan göreceğimiz
unique lock sınıfı
böyle bir
interfejse de sahip
o zaman
hemen hızlı bir şekilde
ilerleyelim
bakın
lock card ile yapabileceğim
sadece
işlemler bunlar
arkadaşlar
ya
doğrudan
mutex'i vereceğim
kilitleyecek
ya
constructora
mutex ile beraber
bu
tek nesnesini
vereceğim
ismi
adapt lock
böylece
kilitli olarak
alacak
ve
arkadaşlar
tekrar
kilitlemeyecek
ama yine
rayi görevini
yerine getirecek
yani destructorı
yine
kilidi
unlock
edecek
şimdi
gelelim
unique lock'a
şimdi unique lock
kabiliyeti
en yüksek olan
guard sınıfı
rayi sınıfı
birçok işleme
olanak veriyor
ve özellikle
ilerleyen saatlerde
bu condition
variable
konusuna
geldiğimizde
koşul değişkenlerine
orada
örneğin
lock guard'ı
ya da
swap lock'ı
kullanma şansımız yok
unique lock
kullanmalıyız
şimdi unique lock'ın
özellikleri
neler
arkadaşlar
bir
default
construct
edebiliyorum
default
construct
ettiğimde
henüz
bakın
bir
mutex ile
ilişkilendirilmiş
durumda
değil
mesela lock
card'ı
default
construct
edemiyorum
tıpkı
lock
card'da
olduğu gibi
bunların hepsi
önemli olduğu için
tek tek üstünden
geçerken beni
takip etmenizi
istiyorum
arkadaşlar
mutex'i
argüman olarak
alan
constructtır
doğal olarak
tıpkı
lock
card'da
olduğu gibi
mutex'i
kilitliyor
ama
bakın şimdi
arkadaşlar
lock
card'da
sadece bu
adapt lock
t
parametreli
constructtır
vardı
bu
ne yapıyordu
zaten
kilitlenmiş
olan bir
mutex'e
ediniyordu
ama
burada
iki
şansımız
daha var
bir tanesi
constructtırın
ikinci
parametresine
bu sefer
yine bir
hang
nesnesi
olan
defer lock
geçmek
nasıl
adapt lock
t
türünden
bir
constex
br
değişkense
sadece
function
overload
resolution
için
kullanılıyorsa
aynı
şekilde
defer lock
da
underscore
t
türünden
bir
constex
br
değişken
yine
function
overload
resolution
ile çalışıyor
bu
çok önemli
çok da
sık
kullanılıyor
neden
unique lock
ın
ikinci
parametresine
konstruktörün
ikinci
parametresine
defer lock
argümanını
geçtiğimiz zaman
kilidi ediniyor
yani kilidi
alıyor
ama
onu kilitlemiyor
buradaki
terminolojide de
çok dikkatli
olmak gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
kilidi ediniyor
derken
kastım
referans
semantiği ile
onu
referans
elemanına
bağlıyor
ama bir de
lock
fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
var
anlaşıldı
değil mi
defer lock
ne yapıyor
evet
kilidi
referans
semantiği ile
ediniyor
ama
konstruktör
mutex'in
lock
fonksiyonunu
çağırmıyor
peki
necati
mutex'in
lock
fonksiyonunu
çağırmıyorsa
nasıl kullanılacak
işte
görüyorsunuz
ya da
birazdan
göreceğiz
arkadaşlar
üye
fonksiyon var
burada
görünmüyor
birazdan
göreceğiz
yani
sınıfın
tıpkı
mutex'in
nasıl
lock
fonksiyonu
varsa
mutex'in
nasıl
unlock
fonksiyonu
varsa
bunlara
map edilmiş
unique lock'ın da
lock ve
unlock fonksiyonları
var
dolayısıyla birçok
uygulamada ne
yapıyoruz
önce
mutex'i
referans
semantiği ile
ediniyoruz
ama sonra
unique lock
sınıfının
kilitlemeye
yönelik
fonksiyonlarından
birini çağırıp
bu da
tabi
tahmin ediyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
lock
ve
belirli bir
süre boyunca
kilitlemeye
çalışan
try lock
for
ve
try lock
until
fonksiyonlarını
çağırıyorum
anlaşıldı mı
ama bir de
şöyle bir
imkan var
şimdi
unique lock'ın
interface ne
kadar geniş
arkadaşlar
doğrudan
constructora
bu sefer
try lock
tag
nesnesine
geçtiğinizde
bunu
ne yapıyor
hem
mutex'i
ediniyor
hem de
kilitlemeye
çalışıyor
ama
bir kere
deniyor
arkadaşlar
bloke olmuyor
dolayısıyla
eğer
bu
constructorı
kullanırsanız
bu durumda
edindiği
referans
semantiliyle
edindiği
mutex nesnesini
bir kez
onun
try lock
fonksiyonuna
çağrı yaparak
kilitlemeye
çalışacak
kilitlerse
kilitlemiş olacak
kilitlememişse
bloke
etmeyecek
tredi
ama
Necati o zaman
kilitlenip
kilitlenmediğini
nereden
anlayacağım
onu da
tahmin ediyorsunuz
onu test
etmeye
yönelik
yine
bir
ya da
iki tane
bir operatör
bul
fonksiyon
olmak istedir
iki tane
üye fonksiyon
var
yine
unique lock'ın
constructorına
bir duration
değeri
geçerek
unique lock
nesnesinin
edindiği
mutex'i
o kadar
duration
boyunca
kilitlemeye
çalışmasını
ama o sürecinde
ya kilitleyecek
ama kilitleyemezse de
yine
bloke olmamasını
sağlıyor
bu
constructor
duration
parametreli
constructor
hemen altında
time point
parametreli bir
constructor da
görüyorsunuz
yani
Necati bir örnek
verebilir misin
tabi hepsine örnek
vereceğim ama
sadece arkadaşlar
şunu göstermek için
bakınız
mesela
diyelim ki
bizim
bir
ant mutex'imiz var
ant mutex
mtx
şimdi bakın
unique lock
bütün
konstruktörleri
göstereyim
şimdi
unique lock
değişken isimlerini
hep
ulak olarak
seçeceğim
arkadaşlar
mtx
bakın bu bir
eğer böyle bir
nesne oluşturursam
git
artık
programın akışı
buraya geldiğinde
kilitlenmiş olma
garantisi var
değil mi
ama kilitlenmemişse
bloke olacak
iki
ben
bu mutex'i
zaten
kilitlemişsem
bu sefer
buna edinmek
için
ikinci parametreye
adapt
lock
geçebilirim
anlaşıldı
değil mi
evet
şimdi artık
bu noktada
zaten ben
kilitli
olarak
aldım
ve
thread
çalışmaya
kilit altında
devam ediyor
devam edelim
peki
böyle çağırırsam
aradaki
fark ne
defer
lock
necati
bu
konstruktörü
çağırırsam
kilitlemeyecek
mutex'e edinecek
fakat kilitlemeyecek
ne işe yarayacak
o zaman
ne zaman
istersem
aslında en önemli
konstruktörlerden biri bu
ne zaman
istersem
bu sefer
ray nesnesinin
kendi
lock
fonksiyonlarından
birini
çağırıp
istediğim zaman
kilitleyeceğim
yani
ray nesnesini
oluşturur
oluşturmaz
mutex'i kilitlemek
zorunda
değilim
bir başka
konstruktör
try lock
da
arkadaşlar
ne istiyor
bizden
evet
şuradaki
argümandan
bahsediyorum
evet
unique lock
mutex
try lock
bu ne istiyor
bizden
ya da ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
altın çizmesine
bakmayın
bu bizden
bu bize ne veriyor
daha doğrusu
kilitlemeye çalışacak
kilitlerse
arkadaşlar
kilide edinmiş olacak
ama
kilitleyemezse
kilitlememiş olacak
ama
thread'i yine
bloke
etmeyecek
anlaşıldı mı
dolayısıyla
eğer böyle bir
konstruktör kullanıyorsam
şimdi kilidin edinilmiş
olup olmadığını
sınamak için
sınıfın
üye fonksiyonlarından
şurada herhalde
bir yazıma
pastoral
evet
şöyle yazın
unique
lock
ulack
mtx
spurt
try
lock
try pull lock
ha değilim try lock
yazmışım o yüzden
try pull lock
evet o benim
anlaşıldı değil mi
şimdi mesela
if
ulack
arkadaşlar
ya operatör
bool
fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
test edebilirim
ya da
on
lock
on slack
fonksiyonu
aynı işi yapıyor
bunlar
arkadaşlar
boolean
değer döndüren
fonksiyonlar
eğer
operatör
bool
fonksiyonu
ya da
on slack
fonksiyonu
true
değer döndürürse
kilit edinilmiş
durumda
demektir
gördüğünüz gibi
ne kadar çok
opsiyon sunuyor
o yüzden
ama
eğer
mutex
aren't mutex
ise
bu örnekte
olduğu gibi
doğrudan
duration'da
geçebiliyorum
mesela
şimdi
burada
arkadaşlar
şu
using
namespace
stud
literals
önce daha kolay
yazma imkanına
sahip oldum
bakın
mtx
diyelim ki
milisaniye
şimdi ne oldu
boyunca
arkadaşlar
edindiğim
mutex'i
kilitlemeye
çalış
milisaniye
sonucunda
kilitlersen
kilitlenmiş
olacak
programlar
için
buraya geldiğinde
buradaki
kodlar
kilit altında
çalışacak
ama kilitleyemezse
bloke
olmayacak
yani ben
daha
constructora
duration
argümanını
geçerek
bu kadar
süre boyunca
kilitlemeye
çalış
diyebiliyorum
arkadaşlar
yalnız bu arada
tabi yanlış anlamı
olmasın
bak bunların
hepsi ayrı
mesela şöyle
yazabilirdim
ulak
mtx
arkadaşlar
deferlak
yani
kilitlemeden
al
ama belki
burada
ulak'ın
ant mutex
olduğu için
trilak
for
ya da
trilak
until
fonksiyonları
da var
yine
buraya
argüman olarak
demin duration
geçmiştik
arkadaşlar
mesela duration
yerine
time point
ile geçebilirim
mesela bakın
ototp
tp1
eşittir
arkadaşlar
steady
clock
krononun
static
clock
fonksiyonunun
navı
mesela
unic
lak
ulak
tp
diyelim
ya da tp1
tp2
eşittir
tp1
krono kütüphanesini
hatırlıyorsunuz
artı
diyelim ki
300 milisaniye
şimdi artık
unic
lak
sınıfının
konstruktörüne
ikinci argüman
olarak
tp2
geçersem
o da
ne anlama
gelecek
şu zaman
şu time point'e
gelene kadar
kilitlemeye
çalış
kilitlersen
kilitleyeceksin
yoksa
blokü olmadan
yoluna
devam
edeceksin
işte bunlar
konstruktörler
unic
lak
özellikle
condition variable'da
bizim için çok önemli
olduğu için buraya
biraz daha ayrıntılı
inmiyorum
unic
lak
bir başka özelliği
daha var
lak
gart
ne kopyalanabiliyor
ne taşınabiliyor
ama
unic
lak
zaten
geçen ders
bir de
neden ismi
unic
lak
diye sormuştuk
bu soruya cevap
vermiştik
unic
lak
ise
taşınabiliyor
yani
her zaman
tek bir
sahibi olacak
mutex'in
tek bir
unic
lak
sahibi
olacak
ama o
sahip
sahipliğe
mülkiyeti
başka bir
unic
lak
nesnesine
devredebilecek
bu da ne demek
unic
lak
nesnelerinin
fonksiyondan
fonksiyona
taşıma
semantiğiyle
geçirilmesi
demek
dolayısıyla
unic
lak
non
copyable
but
movable
ya da
diğer terimiyle
movable
gibi sınıf
tapu sınıflarının en önemli
bir fonksiyonu
aslında
destructorları
çünkü
destructor
hangi lak
sınıfı
olursa olsun
hangi
lak
sınıfı
olursa olsun
destructorı
çalıştığı zaman
sarmaladığı
mutex'in
kilitli olduğunu
test edip
görse
onun
kilidini
açıyor
yani
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
şimdi
unic
lak
ile
neler
yapabiliriz
onlar
demin
gördüğümüz
fonksiyonlar
sınıfın
constructorları
idi
arkadaşlar
global
swap
fonksiyonunu
ya da
sınıfın
üye fonksiyonu
swap'ı
çağırarak
iki
unic
lak
nesnesinin
edindiği
kilitleri
swap
takas
edebiliriz
şimdi
release
fonksiyonu
bu rayı
sınıflarının
release
fonksiyonu
geçen dersimizde
görmüştük
ama bir hatırlatmak istiyorum
pointer döndürüyor
arkadaşlar
böylece
bu
pointer
döndürüyor
ve artık
diyor ki
ben bu
mutex'in
sahibi
değilim
yani
release'i
çağırırsanız
artık
mutex'in
release
fonksiyonu
çağırılmış
rayı
nesnesinin
destraktörü
hiçbir şekilde
mutex'i
unlock
etmeyecek
işlemi için
siz
kendiniz
manuel olarak
release'in
verdiği
mutex
pointer'ını
kullanmalısınız
alttaki iki
fonksiyon
onslug
fonksiyonu
ve
operator
goal
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
mutex'in
kilitli olup
olmadığını
test ediyor
yani
mesela
trial
lock
for
fonksiyonunu
çağırdınız
ama
şunu test
etmek
istiyorsunuz
o süre
boyunca
lock'ı
kiliti
mutex'i
kilitleyebildi mi
yoksa
kilitleyemedi mi
bunu test
etmek için
sınıfın
onslug
ya da
operator
bool
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
bu sınıfın
mutex
fonksiyonu
sarmaladığı
mutex'e
pointer
döndürüyor
ama onu
release etmiyor
release ile
mutex'i
karıştırmayalım
yani mutex
sarmalanan
mutex'in
adresini
get eden
fonksiyon
işte bunlar
zaten
demin
söyledik
lock
kilitliyor
ve bloke
ediyor
trylock
kilitlemeye
çalışıyor
kilitlenirse
true
değer döndürüyor
kilitleyemezse
false
değer döndürüyor
ama bloke
etmiyor
yine aynı
şekilde
trylock
for
ve trylock
until
fonksiyonları
belirli bir süre
boyunca
ya da belirli bir
time point'e
gelinceye
kadar
kilitlemeye
çalışıyor
ama
bloke
etmiyor
arkadaşlar burada
bloke
ediyor
etmiyor
teriminin
ne anlamda
kullanıldığını
geçen derste
söylemiştim
değil mi
yani tıpkı
mutex'lerde
olduğu gibi
yani örneğin
ben
bir
unique
lock
nesnesini
bu şekilde
oluştursaydım
burada
iki tane
ihtimal var
ya
constructor
edindiği kilidi
referans
semantili edindiği kilidi
mutex'i
daha doğrusu
kilitlemiş olacak
ve
bundan sonraki
kod kilit altında
çalışacak
ya da
kilidi edinene
kadar
bu thread
bloke
olacak
olması ne
demek
kilidi edinemediğine
göre
o kilidi
o mutex'i
arkadaşlar
kilitleyemediğine
göre
o mutex'i
kilitlemiş
başka bir
thread var
o ne zaman
unlock
ederse
bizimkinin
onu
arkadaşlar
kilitleme
şansı
doğacak
yani
burada
bizim
threadimiz
bu
nesne
hangi
thread içinde
oluşturulmuşsa
bizim threadimiz
bloke olmuş
olabilir
ya da
olmayabilir
evet işte
üye fonksiyonları
da böyle
arkadaşlar
evet
şimdi burada
hızlı bir şekilde
söylediklerimizin
üstünden
geçelim
sorularınız varsa
da soruları
sorun
benim söylediklerimi
burada şöyle bir
liste şeklinde
yazmış
benim de hoşuma
gittiği için
doğrudan size
buradan göstereyim
dedim
unique lockta
bir ayı sınıfı
çok hızlı
gidelim
bu da bir
sınıf şablonu
bu sınıf şablonunun
da yine
template parametresi
arkadaşlar
edinilecek
mutex'in
türü
yani
örneğin
unique lock'ın
mutex açılımı
timed mutex
açılımı gibi
ama
eğer
constructora
argüman olarak
bir mutex
verirseniz
unique lock
ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
template argümanını
yazmasanız
dahi
class template argument
deduction'da
template argümanının
hangi mutex
bürü olduğu
anlaşılıyor
evet
template parametresi
bu
arkadaşlar
template parametresi
karşılığı herhangi bir template argümanı
geçebilirsiniz
yani unique lock'ın
mutex
unique lock'ın
timed mutex'i
ama
burada dikkat bakın
generic program
olmanın çok iyi bir örneği
mesela
soruya bakın şimdi
ben
buradaki
mutex
timed mutex
olmasaydı
doğrudan
stud mutex
olsaydı
ve ben
yine
unique lock
kullansaydım
tamam
yine
buradaki
mutex'i
kilitleyecekti
ama artık
bakın
interfaste
az önce olan
arkadaşlar
try lock
for
vesaire
bu
try lock
diyorum
for
try lock
until
fonksiyonları
yok
çünkü
onların olması
için
mutex'in
minimal
timed
mutex olması
lazım
ama
burada
bu
interfais yok
yine aynı
şekilde
arkadaşlar
burada
mutex edilmesi
için
belirli bir süre
değeri de
veremem
onu
o overloadda
yine
olmayacak
hocam
t yerine
çok farklı bir
sınıf tipi
geçersek
compile time
hatası
alırız
değil mi
hayır
bu da çok
güzel bir
soru
alabiliriz
ama
almak zorunda
değiliz
neden
olsam
bu çok
önemli bir
soru
neden
çünkü
mutex sınıfları
standart
olmak zorunda
değil
mesela
diyelim ki
siz
boost
kütüphanesini
kullanıyorsunuz
ya da
üçüncü partta
bir kütüphane
kullanıyorsunuz
ama
o kütüphanede
de
belki
farklı bir
interfase
sahip
bir
mutex
sınıfı
var
siz şöyle
diyebilir
misiniz
mesela
böyle bir
sınıf
olsaydı
class
my
mutex
yani
bu herhangi
bir mutex
sınıfı
arkadaşlar
peki
şimdi
ben
diyelim ki
stud
unique
kütüphanede
buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar
my mutex
açıldı mı
desem
böyle bir
kod olabilir
mi
olabilir
ama
buraya dikkat
işte
böyle bir sınıfın
kullanılabilmesi
için
arkadaşlar
bu sınıfın
belirli garantileri
vermesi gerekiyor
işte onlar
konsept konusuna
geldiğimiz zaman
bunları da
göreceğiz
c++
20 standartından
önce bunlar
sadece
dokümante ediliyordu
mesela
arkadaşlar
bu
unique
lock
bunu kilitleyecek
değil mi
kilitlemesi için
mutex'in
lock
fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
ama bunun
lock
fonksiyonu
yok
işte
bakın
eğer bu
gereklilikleri
yerine
getirirse
mesela
diyelim ki
tabi
gerçek bir
kod
yazmayacağım
böyle bir
lock
fonksiyonu
var
efendim
böyle bir
unlock
fonksiyonu
var
artık
bu fonksiyonları
kendi fonksiyonlarını
map edebileceği
böyle lock
unlock fonksiyonları
ya da gereken
bütün o
interfezi
sağlıyorsa
Ozan Bey
bu da bir
template argümanı
olabilir
hiçbir engel
yok
işte arkadaşlar
o yüzden
standart kütüphane
c++
standartından
önce
bu
gerekliliklere
işaret eden
bazı
isimler
kullanıyor
bunlar
standart kütüphanenin
dokümantasyonunda
kullanılan
isimler
mesela şöyle
olduğunu düşünün
lockable
yani
diyor ki
örneğin
unique lock'ın
diyor
arkadaşlar
bunu bir yazayım
evet
mesela diyor ki
unique lock'ın
template argümanının
lockable
gerekliliklerini
İngilizce
requirement'larını
karşılaması
gerekiyor
diyor
bu durumda
sadece
standart
mutex
sınıfları
değil
işte o
gereklilikleri
karşılayan
herhangi bir
mutex sınıfını
template argümanı
olarak
kullanabiliriz
demek
anlaşıldı mı
yani bunlarla
yetinmek zorunda
değiliz
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
unique lock'tan
bahsettik
ve işte
gördüğümüz gibi
unique lock
olabilecek
en yetenekli
ne sınıfı
rayı sınıfı
ama tabii
onu kullanmanın da
bir
maliyeti var
şimdi
mutex'lere
gelelim
mesela
arkadaşlar
yine aynı şekilde
şimdi ben şöyle yazsaydım
bakın
başlangıçta konu
basit gibi görünüyor
ama işin içine
girince
ince noktalar
önem kazanıyor
mesela şöyle bir şey
yapsam
Oğuzhan Bey'e
sorusuna benzer
başka bir soru
sorayım
diyelim ki
benim elimde
unique lock
nesnesi var
ve
arkadaşlar
burada
nesneyi
oluşturdum
ulock
konstruktörüne
da
argüman olarak
şöyle bir
mutex
geçtim
stud mutex
mtx
artık bunu
açıklamaya gerek
yok değil mi
böyle yazmakla
aslında
unique lock'ın
mutex
açılımı
yazmak
aynı şey
yani
tamket argümanını
yazmamam
sitat
nedeniyle
ama başka bir
soru sorduk
mesela
şimdi şöyle bir şey
olsaydı
diyelim ki
ben
döngüsel bir
yapı içinde
bir nedenden
gerektiğini
düşünelim
ki
ona birazdan
bahsedeceğiz
bunu
birden fazla
keskilik
deseydim
şimdi
tanımsız
davranış
olacaktı
ulock
aslında
lock
fonksiyonu var
arkadaşlar
bakın bir
sentax
atas değil
ama
buradaki
davranışın
güvenilir
olması için
burada çağrılan
her ne kadar
biz rayı sınıfının
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsak
o da ne yapıyor
aslında
sarmaladı
mutex'in
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
öyle değil mi
dolayısıyla
burada tanımsız
davranış olacak
ama bakın
eğer bu
stud mutex
değil de
recursive
mutex
olsaydı
o zaman
lock
nesnemizi
arkadaşlar
bu şekilde
kullanmak
şöyle yapalım
yine
sitaptan
faydalanalım
herhangi bir
şekilde
tanımsız
davranış
olmayacaktı
şimdi
bu
recursive
mutex'in
kullanıldığı
iki tane
temel senaryo var
ikisi de önemli
biri
adı üstünde
recursive fonksiyonlar
doğrusu isterseniz
burada ihtiyaç
daha az
asıl
ikinci senaryo
İngilizce'de
active object
dediğimiz
örüntüde
yani
aslında bir sınıfın
bütün üye fonksiyonlarının
kilit altında
çalışması
teması
ama ben
mesela recursive
bir örnek vereyim
arkadaşlar
izleyin
bir tane
recursive
fonksiyonumuz olsa
volt
refank
yani burada
isim
sadece bunun
recursive fonksiyon
olduğunu
öz yinelemeli
kendi kendini
çağıran bir fonksiyon
diyelim ki
birinci parametresi
arkadaşlar
charge
c
ikinci parametresi
int
n
kodun da şöyle
olduğunu düşünelim
bakın
çok basit
bir recursive fonksiyon
yazıyorum
n
sıfırdan
küçükse
arkadaşlar
fonksiyon return
etsin
aksi halde
arkadaşlar
önce kilit
kullanmayacağım
efendim
şöyle bir
standart
altta yazı
yazdırsın
stutz
c
alt
önce karakteri
yazdırsın
evet
hatta bir de
g count değişkenimiz olsun
bunun değeri de
sıfır
karakteri yazdıktan
sonra
bir
boşluk versin
ve ondan
ondan sonra da
arkadaşlar
artı artı
g count
ifadesinin
değerini yazdırsın
fakat
bundan sonra
dikkat
kendisini
bu kez
yine
aynı
karakter
ve
eneksi
bir değeriyle
çağırsın
arkadaşlar
şimdi bu tipik bir recursive fonksiyon
değil mi
kesinlikle
yani normalde
ben bu recursive fonksiyonu
single thread
çalıştırmak
istesem
refhunk
eğer yanlış bir şey
yapmadıysam
örneğin
artı
karakteri
5 kez
bu
herhangi bir recursive fonksiyon olduğunu
düşünün
şu
kapanmamış
evet
bir dakika
e
ekse bir şey mi
çalışıyor
arkada
şunların hepsini
kapatalım
evet
arkadaşlar
artı artı
g count
artı artı yapalım
bunda
en küçük
return
evet
bir hata
yok
evet
bakın
birinci kez
artı
eğer ben
9 değerini verseydim
bu 9'a kadar gidecekti
yani burada
sadece bunun bir recursive fonksiyon olduğunu
özinelemeli fonksiyon olduğunu göstermek için yazıyorum
ya da şuna bakın
arkadaşlar
new line
bir nokta karakteri olsaydı
şimdi gelelim temaya
peki
ben bunu
birden fazla thread tarafından çalıştırılmasını istersem
o zaman g count
global değişken
neden şimdi global değişken kullandığımı anladınız değil mi
multi thread'e senaryo olsun
yani senkronizasyon gerekiyor
burayı anladık mı
şimdi g count'un ve hatta c out'un ayrışımlı kullanılması söz konusu olduğu için
burada senkronizasyon gerekiyor
e şimdi ben burada bir tane mutex kullansam
arkadaşlar
stud mutex
mtx
işte burada
kritik bölgenin başında
mtx'in lag fonksiyonunu çağırsam
burada da mtx'in unlag fonksiyonunu çağırsam
ama şimdi şöyle bir problem var
fonksiyon kendi kendini çağırdığında
bizim mutex'imiz
ikinci kez kilitlenmiş olacak
dolayısıyla burada bir
hanımsız davranış var
arkadaşlar evet
bu arada
böyle durumlarda
diyor ki standart
eğer implementasyon
burada örneğin bir deadlock
oluşumunu
tespit ederse
arkadaşlar o zaman
exception throw edebilir
hatta orada throw edeceğin exception ile ilgili
yine bir error kodunun ne olduğuna bağlı olarak
ne nedenle exception throw ettiğini de anlayabiliyorsunuz
ama konumuz o değil
ama şimdi burada mutex yerine
recursive mutex kullanırsam
arkadaşlar
izleyin
şimdi
birden fazla thread bunu çalıştırdığı zaman
herhangi bir şekilde problem olmayacak
ya da
tek bir thread çalıştırdığında
arkadaşlar ikinci kez kilitlenmesi
problem olacak
önce
sadece main thread'den çalıştıralım
aradaki fark
mutex'i
recursive mutex yapmamız
stut
recursive
mutex
mtx
bakın herhangi bir şekilde problem olmadı
hatta şimdi
üç ayrı thread'den çalıştıralım
efendim
stut
c thread
p1
refank
ama argüman olarak
diyelim ki
nokta
ya da büyük harf x
5 kez
p2
refank
büyük harf y
5 kez
yine
deadlock
oluşmayacak
görüyorsunuz değil mi
fakat
asıl önemli senaryo
geçen derste örnek vermiştik
active object senaryosu
arkadaşlar
yani buradaki tema şu
hatırlıyorsunuz
aslında siz
sınıfın bütün
üye fonksiyonlarını
member fonksiyonlarını
bir
mutex altında
kilitlenmiş bir mutex altında
çalıştırıyorsunuz
kilit altında
böylece
data res
oluşmayacak
ama
arkadaşlar
bir üye fonksiyon
başka bir üye fonksiyonu
da çağırabiliyor
bu durumda bunlar
aynı mutex'i
kullandığı için
bir üye fonksiyon
mutex'i
lock ettiği zaman
kendisi de
başka bir üye fonksiyonu
çağırdığında
iki üye fonksiyonda
sınıfın
veri elemanı
data memberı olan
aynı mutex'i
kullandığı için
mutex
birden fazla
kes kilitlenmiş oluyor
yine tanımsız davranış
olmaması için
mutex'in
recursive mutex
olması gerekiyor
recursive olmayan
fonksiyonlarda
recursive mutex
kullanması
compound time
hatası mı?
değil
ama gereksiz bir
maliyet eklemiş
oluyorsunuz
arkadaşlar tabi
recursive mutex
içinde
örneğin
kaç kez kilitlendiği
bilgisini
vesaire
onları tutuyor
dolayısıyla
normal
bizim basit
adi
standart
ilk
minimal mutex'imize göre
daha büyük bir
neye sahip
overhead'e sahip
yani ilave maliyete
sahip
işte
geçen verdiğimiz örnek
bir
örneğin
aşağı yukarı
aynısı
burada
sadece şunu
göstermek istiyorum
arkadaşlar
izleyin
bir
database
access
isimli bir
sınıf var
sınıfın
üye fonksiyonları
var
create table
insert data
and insert data
tabi biraz
zorlama bir
senaryo oldu
ama
buradaki
esprinin ne
olduğunu
tahmin
edebiliyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
burada
örneğin
insert data
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsanız
tamam
lagart'la
kilit altında
çalıştıracak
bir problem
yok
aynı şekilde
create table
da bir problem
yok
ama bu
fonksiyon
isminin
ne olduğuna
bakmayın
bu fonksiyon
hem kendi
operasyonları
için
burada bir
kilit
kullanıyor
arkadaşlar
ama
create table
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
orada da
sınıfın
veri elemanı
olan
mutex
kullanıldı
dolayısıyla
eğer ben
burada
recursive
mutex
kullanıyor
olmasaydım ki
şimdi
kullanmadım
ne olacak
deadlock
oluşacak
neden
ikinci kez
kilitleyecek
yani
create table
fonksiyonunun
içinde
19.
satırdaki
kod
mutex'i
kilitleyecek
ama
create table
çağırıldığında
7.
satırdaki
kod
aynı
mutex'i
yine
kilitleyecek
burada
mutex'in
lag fonksiyonunu
çağırmadığıma
bakmayın
lagart zaten
bu işi yapıyor
değil mi
bakın
en azından
belki runtime'da
görme şansımız var
evet
gördüğünüz gibi
arkadaşlar
terminate
edildi
programımız
ama burada
mutex yerine
veri elemanını
recursive
mutex
türünden
yapsaydık
bir problem
olmayacaktı
evet
şurada
tabi bakın
şimdi
recursive
mutex olduğu için
şuraları
değiştirmem
gerekiyor
bari ben de
statten
faydalı
bakın
statın
ne kadar
faydalı olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
baştan
statten
faydalan
saydım
bu değişikliği
yapmak zorunda
kalmayacak
şimdi
demin
arkadaşımın
sorusu
emranın
sorusunda
şunu söyleyeyim
aslında
minimal
mutex
kullanmak
yerine
unique
lock
da
kullanabilirsiniz
ama
minimal
size yetiyorsa
daha
fazla
yeteneğe
sahip
yani
capabilitiesi
daha yüksek
olan sınıfı
kullanmak
sadece
programımızın
olsa olsa
daha yavaş çalışması
sonucunda
yavaş derken
burada
tabii
görecek
bunun belki
tek istisnası
arkadaşlar
bu
scope lock'ı
kullanmak
yani çünkü
standart
açıkça
scope lock'ı
lock guard
gibi kullandığınız
zaman
efektif olarak
onun yerine
geçebileceğin
yani ilave
maliyet
olmayacağını
söylemiş
evet
şimdi
aynı
durumu
gösterecek
bir küçük
kod daha
yazıyorum
izleyin
şimdi
konu çok fazla olunca
kodların hepsini
bakın şu dört kodu yazdık
neredeyse
birinci dersimiz
bitiyor
bakın bir örnek
daha
full fonksiyonu
mutex'i
kilitledi
ama
recursive
mutex
arkadaşlar
thread'in id'sini
yazdırdı
ve
full çağrıldı
yazısını yazdırdı
fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışması bitince
full sona eriyor
yazısını yazdırdı
ama bunlar
mutex altında
kilitli
kilit altında
arkadaşlar
burada ise
fund fonksiyonu
yine
çalışır çalışmaz
mutex'i kilitliyor
ve
çağrıldığını gösteren
bir yazı yazdırıyor
ama
fung da
full'yu çağırıyor
bu durumda
fung fu'yu çağırdığında
mutex
ikinci kez kilitlenmiş oluyor
recursive mutex olmasaydı
problem olacaktı
ama bakın
recursive mutex
olmadığı zaman
böylece
kilitlemeyi
bilen
görmüş olacağız
bakın şimdi
id'li
thread
çalıştırılmış
fung fonksiyonu
çağrılmış
arkadaşlar
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
şuradan bahsediyorum
legend fung'a
çağrıldı
fung fu'yu çağırıyor
fu sona eriyor
fung sona eriyor
tekrar fung çağrılıyor
fu çağrılıyor
fu sona eriyor
fung sona eriyor
herhangi bir şekilde
ikinci kez kilitlenmesinden
bir problem
olmadığını görüyoruz
fung mutex'te ise
işte
tek esprisi
diğerine göre
arkadaşlar
işin içine
bir duration
ve time point
girebiliyor
yani
artık
time mutex'te
şu kadar süre boyunca
kilidi edinmeye
çalış
diyebiliyoruz
tabi bunun şöyle
bir faydası var
kilidi edinirse
o paylaşımlı
değişkenleri
kaynakları
kullanacak
ama kilidi edinemezse de
başka bir iş
yapmasını
sağlayabilirsiniz
evet
mesela
bir örnek
bunun içinde
sadece burada amaç
time mutex'e
bir örnek olması
daha fazlası değil
evet
olsa nesin
hocam tam olarak
bununla ilgili
soru soracaktım
iş yerinde
benzer bir sorun vardı
recursive mutex
bilmediğim için
private overloadlar
yazmıştım
mutex'si
evet
anladım
yani
recursive mutex
olsaydı
bunları yazmama
gerek kalmayacak
arkadaşlar burada
tabi şöyle bir problem var
bu standart kütüphaneyle ilgili
C'de de
C++'da da
benim ilk anlattığım şey
işte standart kütüphanedeki
öğeleri
bilmediğimiz zaman
mesela böyle bir öğe var
ama bilmiyorum
bu bir algoritma olabilir
özellikle algoritmalarda
bu çok sık oluyor
o zaman programcı
meshwork
örneğin o algoritmayı
implemente etmeye
çalışıyor
implemente ettiği zaman
onu test etmesi
gerekiyor
unit test yapması
implemente ettiği zaman
efficiency problemi de
olabiliyor
mesela belki de
algoritma
n-logen karmaşıklığında
ama
onu n-kare karmaşıklığında
yazıyor
dolayısıyla
önce gerçekten
standart kütüphanede
bunu yapacak bir
araç var mı
ona bakmak gerekiyor
concurrency
söz konusuysa
orada
ikinci bir seçenek
acaba ben
bu belirli bir
işletim sitemi
için yazılıyorsa
mesela
yazdığınız kod
acaba
ilgili sınıfın
native handle
fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
orada bir şey
yapabilir miyim
sizin örneğiniz için
söylemiyorum ama
evet
şimdi bakın
burada da
time mutex
kullanılmış
kullanıldığı için
şuradaki
variable döngüsüne
bakın
arkadaşlar
eğer
time mutex
olmasaydı
bu
trial lock
for
fonksiyonu
interfeisinde
olmayacaktı
çağıramayacaktım
şimdi aslında
burada
konuyu göstermek için
de çok güzel bir örnek
bakınız
aslında bütün
espri şu
ben
iki fonksiyonda
iki ayrı
thread'ten
çalıştırıyorum
ama
önce
arkadaşlar
şuraya bir gecikme
koydum ki
200 milisaniye
burası
şuraya kadar
ilerlesin
böylece
önce
buradaki
gecikme
nedeniyle
her ne kadar
deterministik
olmasa da
işte o amaçla
buraya gecikmeyi
koydum
bu task
mutex'i
önce kilitleyecek
kilitli
mutex'i
kilitleyecek
arkadaşlar
efendim
şu yazı
çıkacak
ama burada
5 saniye
bekleyecek
şimdi burada
5 saniye
beklerken
ben
yine
buradaki
time mutex'in
try lock
for
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
her
500 milisaniye
her çağrıda
kilitlemeye
çalışmasını
istiyorum
ama
false değer
döndükçe
tekrar
çağırıyorum
böylece
arkadaşlar
neyi
size göstermiş
olacağım
ya o
5 saniye
geçerken
her
yarım
saniyede
bir
aslında
ekrana
bar
task
couldn't lock
the mutex
yazı
çıkacak
ne zaman ki
buradaki
5 saniye
geçecek
bu task
mutex'i
unlock edecek
unlock ederken de
biz şu yazıyı
göreceğiz
ondan sonra
bizim
bu döngünün
falanca
turunda
artık
try lock
for
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
true değer
dönecek
ve
döngüden
çıkacak
gerçekten
değerleyip
çalıştıralım
evet
bakın
her
milisaniyede
bir
denedi
hatta
şimdi
biraz
eğlenceli
olsun
şurayı
milisaniyeye
çekin
yani
try lock
for
milisaniye
argümanıyla
çağırıyorum
bakın
sürekli
deniyor
burada
biz sadece
ekrana
mutex'i
edinemediği
yazısını
yazdırıyoruz
ama
arkadaşlar
eğer başarısız
olursa
mesela burada
başka bir takım
işlemler
yapıyor
olabilir
değil mi
şimdi
şu koda
bakalım
birazdan
ara vereceğim
evet burada
yine
time mutex
var
g counter
isimli bir
değişkenim var
işte
paylaşımlı
değişken
increment
fonksiyonunda
her
mikrosaniyede
bir
kilidi
edinmeye
çalışıyor
kilidi
edindiğinde
g counter
değişkeninin
değerini
bir arttırıyor
arkadaşlar
ve
10 milisaniye
bekliyor
ondan sonra
bu kritik bölgeye
girdi
yazısını
yazıyor
ve
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
eğer
kilitlemeyi
başaramazsa
if'in
else kısmı
çalışacak
ve
bu
thread
kritik bölgeye
giremedi
yazısı
çıkacak
burada
fonksiyonun
parametresi
yine birden fazla
thread olması
durumunda
hangi
thread'in
bunları
yazdırdığına
yönelik
yani
i'yi
doğrudan
thread
id olarak
kullanıyorum
çünkü
gerçek
thread
id yazdırsam
o sayı
bana bir şey
ifade etmeyecek
evet
arkadaşlar
bakınız
çalıştıralım
şimdi
evet
arkadaşlar
burada bir şey
daha görüyorsunuz
bakın
bu yazının
böyle garbut
çıkmasının
nedeni
see out
nesnesini
ne yapmamam
senkronize
etmemem
ama
see out
nesnesi
thread save
karakter bazında
ama tabi
yazının
tamamını
tamamlayabilmek
zorunda
değil
izleyin
üretimde
az mı
kullanılıyor
derken
hangisi
üretimde
az mı
kullanılıyor
yok
time mutex
çok ihtiyaç
duyulan
bir mutex
türü
yani az
kullanılıyor
cümlesi
pek doğru
olmazdı
zaten
bundan sonraki
örneklerde de
belirli bir süre
boyunca kilitlemeye
çalışma teması
karşımıza çıkacak
ama bakın
şimdi
programın
çıktısına
bakın
burada
arkadaşlar
demin
yazı
gargled
çıkmıştı
şimdi
çıkmadı
ama yazının
her zaman
düzgün
çıkmasını
isteseydim
arkadaşlar
burada
zaten
bir problem
yok
bakın
çünkü
try luck
for
fonksiyonunu
true
döndürürse
burası
kilit altında
çalışacak
ama
arkadaşlar
burası
kilit altında
çalışmıyor
onun için de
şöyle bir şey
yapsam
c++
20 ile
gelen
osing stream
sınıfını
kullansam
spurt
osing stream
konstakterine
argüman olarak
onu verdim
şimdi muhtemelen
eğer başka bir yeri
kaçırmamışsam
o yazılar da
düzgün çıkacak
her zaman
evet
thread 1
kritik bölgeye
girdi
thread 2
kritik bölgeye
giremedi
şimdi
bir tane daha
ekleyelim
t3
arkadaşlar
inkran
bunda
3 olsun
join edelim
ya da
şöyle yapalım
şuraya
bir nesn
bro
kuralım
böylece
c thread'e de
yavaş yavaş
sizi
oluşturmuş
olayım
bunları
c thread
nesneleri
yapayım
evet
thread 1
kritik bölgeye
girdi
thread 2
ve 3
kritik bölgeye
giremedi
şimdi
bu
50 mikrosaniye
edinmeye
çalıştı
şunu biraz azaltalım
pardon
milisaniye değil
mikrosaniye
tabu yine
hangisinin oraya
gireceği
deterministik
değil
thread 1
kritik bölgeye
girdi
thread 2
kritik bölgeye
giremedi
şu süreyi
arttıralım
arkadaşlar
mikrosaniye
yapalım
milisaniye
evet
farklı
süre değerleri
için
deneme
yapacaktım
ama
gerek de yok
bir ara verelim
şimdi
saat
21.05
21.25
de devam
edeceğiz
devam
ediyoruz
arkadaşlar
birinci
derste
bir örnek
verecektim
ama erken
olduğu için
yarıda bıraktım
şimdi örneği
vermemde bir
engel yok
bakın şimdi
bu global
stud lag
fonksiyonu
normalde
bu lag
fonksiyonu
variadik
fonksiyon
ve
variadik
parametrelerine
mutexleri de
rayi
nesnelerinde
alabiliyor
fakat
burada
dead lag
kaçınmak
için
birden fazla
mutex'i
kilitlemek
isteyen
full
fonksiyonu
stud lag
fonksiyonunu
kullanıyor
ve stud lag
fonksiyonuyla
mtx1 ve
mtx
isimli
iki tane
mutex'i
kilitliyor
burada
hatırlayın
artık
sıranın
bir önemi
yok
algoritma
lag'ın
kendi içinde
kullandığı
algoritma
bunu
implemente ediyor
aslında
buradaki
senaryoda
şöyle olduğunu
düşünelim
bu
mutex'lerden
biri
yedinci
satırda
tanımlanan
shared
val
diğeri de
shared
val
değişkenini
senkronize
etmek için
onlarda
data race
oluşmaması
için
ama
şimdi
bakın
mutex'ler
kilitlendi
normalde
işim bittiğinde
bunların
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırmam
lazım
ama
diyorum ki
kilitli de
olsa
ben yine
ray nesnesi
kullanacağım
ve burada
arkadaşlar
lock 1
isimli
lock
kart
nesnesinin
constructor'ının
ikinci parametresine
adapt
lock
argümanı
geçerek
mutex'i
edinmiş oldum
yani referans
hematili
mutex zaten
kilitli
şimdi
artık
shared
file 1
için
mutex'imi
kilitli
şekilde
aldım
ona
data race
olmadan
eriştim
diyelim ki
onun değerini
10 arttırdım
fakat bu noktada
diğer mutex'i
kilitledim
ya daha doğrusu
kilitledim demeyelim de
edindim
çünkü mutex'in
kilitlenmesi
lock fonksiyonuyla
oldu
ve diğer değişkeni
kullandım
şimdi buraya
kaç tane
thread girerse
girsin
herhangi bir
şekilde bir
sorun
olmayacak
mesela derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
tabi bu kodda
anlatmak istediğim
nokta
sadece
şu
ikinci
parametre
fonksiyonun
constructor'ın
ikinci
parametresine
geçinen
adapt lock
mutex'i ediniyor
ama onun kilitli
olduğunu
bilerek ediniyor
ama yine
destructor
çağrıldığını
yani
bu fonksiyonun
ana bloğunun
sonunda
burada
hem lock
bir
hem de
lock
iki
nesnelerinin
scope'larının
sonunu bu
closing
place belirlediği
için
programın
bu noktaya
geldiğinde
lock
guard
türünden
ismi lock
bir
ve lock
iki olan
nesneler için
destructor
çağrılacak
ve bu
destructorlar
MTX1 ve
MTX2
mutex'lerini
unlock
edecek
yani kilidi
açacak
arkadaşlar
önce bir
deadlock
oluşmayacak
evet
devam
şimdi
unique lock'a
tekrar geçiyoruz
unique lock'ın
yetenekleri ve
bu yetenekleri
nasıl
kullanırız
birinci
derste biraz
göstermiştim
ama şimdi hazır
örnek üstünde
de görelim
arkadaşlar
evet
şimdi bakın
F1
fonksiyonu
içinde
doğrudan
tabi burada
kodlar olduğunu
düşünüyoruz
sadece bu
kısmı
gösteriyorum
burada
lock isimli
değişken
mutex'i
kilitliyor
konstruktöründe
doğrudan
mutex geçilmiş
yukarıdaki gibi
yazmakla
aşağıdaki gibi
yazmak
yine
C++
standardıyla
dileklenen
o meşhur
citat kuralı
ona olanak
sağlıyor
yani programın
akışı
buraya geldiğinde
buradaki
kodlar
arkadaşlar
under
locked
mutex
kilitlenmiş
altında
çalışıyor
f2
fonksiyonunda
ise
önce
mutex'in
kendi
lock
fonksiyonu
çağrılmış
yani
mutex kilitlenmiş
fakat
unique lock
sınıfının
konstruktörünün
ikinci
parametresine
adapt lock
sabiti
geçilmiş
böylece
kilitli
olarak
edinmiş
oldum
onu
ama yine
scope'umun sonunda
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağıracağım
burada bir
görünmeyen
unlock
çağrısı var
f3'de ise
buraya dikkat
bu sefer
konstruktörün
ikinci parametresine
defer lock
argümanını
geçtim
yani
referansım
unique lock
nesnesinin
veri elemanı
olan
mutex
referansı
bu
mutex'e
bağlandı
ama
onu kilitlemedi
ne zaman
ben lock
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsam
tabi eğer bu
stut mutex
değil de
tank mutex
olsaydı
sadece
lock fonksiyonu
değil
arkadaşlar
try lock
for ve
until
fonksiyonlarını
da çağırabilecektim
ama
diyelim ki
burada lock
fonksiyonuyla
kilitledim
ama
yine
burada
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırmıyorum
çünkü
scope'un sonunda
unlock
edecek
ve
f4 fonksiyonunda ise
bu sefer
unique lock
sınıfının
konstruktörünün
ikinci parametresine
try to lock
sabiti
geçilmiş
bu da ne demek
burada
kilitlemeye çalışacak
ya kilitleyecek
ya kilitlemeyecek
ama
bloke olmayacak
işte görüyorsunuz
ondan sonraki
ilk deyiminde
eğer
on start
fonksiyonu
true değer
döndürürse
burada
bu kod
kilit altında
çalışıyor
demektir
burada başka
bir seçenek
sınıfın
on start
fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
yerine
doğrudan
operatör
bul
fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
olabilirdi
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
unique lock
bir başka
önemli özelliği
birden fazla
kilitleyip
kilidi
tekrar açabilirim
birden fazla
derken
kilitliyken
tekrar kilitlemekten
bahsetmiyorum
onu da yapabiliriz
ama
onun için
sarmalanan
mutex'in
recursive mutex
olması gerekiyor
ama
diyelim ki
ulak
yine
benim bir
unique lock
nesnem
şunu yapabilirim
değil mi
ulak
burada kilidi
mutex'i kilitledim
kilit altında
kodları
çalıştırdım
kod
sum kod
arkadaşlar
burada
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
sanki doğrudan
mutex'i
kullanıyormuşum
gibi
ama
burada
arada belki
başka kodlar var
sonra
burası da
benim için
bir kritik bölge ise
tekrar
ulak
ve
sonra tekrar
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırabilirim
yani bunun
bir kere
olması
gerekmiyor
işte bu kodda da
onu
göstermeye
çalışacağım
izleyin
biraz hızlı
geçelim
buraları
evet
arkadaşlar
burada yine
paylaşımlı olarak
kullanılacak
ismi
gcount olan
bir değişken
var
bir de
stut mutex
turundan
mtx
değişkenim
var
bu döngü
bir milyon
kez dönüyor
ama bakın
sadece mutex'in
uniclock
nesnesinin
kullanılmasına
örnek olsun
diye
döngünün her
turunda
uniclock
nesnemiz
konstrakt
oluyor
ama
konstraktörüne
differlock
argümanı
geçildiği için
arkadaşlar
kilitlemeyi
yapmadı
ama
burada kilitlemeyi
yaptı
şimdi burada
Türkçe terminolojide
de şöyle bir problem
çıkıyor
onu da bir
birlikte çözelim
arkadaşlar
şimdi buradaki
edinme
sözü
fiili
mutex'in
kilitlenmesi
anlamında
ama bir de
şöyle bir şey var
bakın
mutex'i
referans
semantiyle
alması ya da
almaması
şimdi
mutex
guard sınıfları
tipik olarak
şöyle sınıflar
mesela
class
basit değiştirmiş
olarak
şey yapıyorum
class
ne olsun
arkadaşlar
lock guard
bakın
template
type name
m
mutex'in
m'si
aslında ne var
burada bir
veri elemanı var
değil mi
private
mutex
türünden
referans
mutex
şimdi siz sınıfın
şu konstruktörünü
çağırdığınızda
public
arkadaşlar
lock guard
efendim
m türünden
referans
rm
ne yapıyor
bu konstruktör
gidiyor
veri elemanı
olan referansı
parametreye gelen
mutex'e
bağlıyor
böylece artık
benim
lock guard
bunun herhangi bir
rai sınıfı
olduğunu düşünün
benim
rai sınıfımın
fonksiyonları
neyi kullanma
şansına sahip
veri elemanı
olan referansı
kullanma şansına
sahip
referansı
kullandığımız zaman
neyi
kullanmış oluyoruz
aslında konstruktör'a
gönderilen
argümanı
kullanmış oluyoruz
mesela
burada
sınıfın
lock isimli bir fonksiyonu
olsa
lock fonksiyonu
şöyle implemente edilmiş
olacak değil mi
mtx
lock
takip edebiliyor muyuz
efendim
unlock fonksiyonu da
şu şekilde
implemente edilmiş
olacak
unlock
mtx
anlaşıldı
değil mi
şimdi
mutex'e edinmekten
kastım
bazen
bunu özellikle
vurgulamak için
referans
semantiğiyle
ediniyorum
diyorum
yani bu şu
demek
mesela
lock
guard
mtx
şimdi
mutex'in
sahibiyim
ama bu
konstruktör gitti
aynı zamanda
mutex'in
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırdı
ya da
işte şu
üye fonksiyonunu
çağırdı
gibi düşün
ama bakın
iş
unique lock
nesnesine
gelince
unique lock
nesnesi
default
konstruktor edilebiliyor
değil mi
yani şöyle
bir unique lock
nesnesi de
oluşturabilirim
o zaman
unique lock
izleyin
mutex açılımı
lock
şimdi
mesela lock
card'ın böyle bir
konstruktörü yok
ama unique lock'ın
böyle bir
konstruktörü var
şimdi bu
mutex herhangi bir
mutex'e edindi mi
hayır
ama daha sonradan
edinebilir
örneğin
değil mi
hocam nasıl
daha sonra edinebilir ki
aşama semantiği
var ya
mesela şöyle bir
mutex olsaydı
şöyle bir
unique lock
nesnesi
olsaydı
stut
arkadaşlar
unique lock
evet
diyelim ki
x lock
mtx
mtx'de
mutex olsun
altını çizmekse
bakmayın
şimdi şunu
yazabilirim
değil mi
lock
eşittir
stut
move
taşıma semantiği
böyle durumlarda
işe yarıyor
dolayısıyla taşıma
semantiğine açık
olduğu için
ne yapma
şansına sahibim
default
konstrukt edip
sonra
mutex'i
edinmesini
sağlayabilirim
edinmekten
kastım
guard
ya da
rayi
sınıf
nesnesinin
elemanı
olan referansın
o mutex'e
bağlanması
ama bazen de
yine
ingilizce'de de
aynı problem var
bazen de
mutex'i
elde ediyor
ediniyor
gibi cümlelerde
mutex'i
herhangi bir
thread kilitleyebilir
değil mi
orada mutex'in
kilitlenmesinden
bahsediliyor
yani şu anda
diyelim global
böyle bir
mutex varsa
bu 10 tane
thread
bu mutex'i
kullanıyorsa
biri
lock ettiğinde
öbürleri
arkadaşlar
artık
kritik bölgeye
geldiğinde
orada
blokü
olacaklar
dolayısıyla
şu ikisi
farklı şey
a
bir
rayi nesnesi
örneğin
unique lock
bir mutex'e
bağlanmış
olabilir
ya da
olmayabilir
b
bir
unique lock
nesnesinin
veri elemanı
olan referans
mutex
bir mutex'e
bağlanmıştır
ama
o mutex'i
kilitli durumda
kullanmaktadır
ya da
kilitli
değildir
o ayrı bir
konu
anlaşıldı
değil mi
peki
şimdi bu koda
bakalım
bir milyon kez
dönen döngüde
differ lock
argümanıyla
unique lock
nesnemi
oluşturduğum
için
kilidi
mutex'i
kilitlemeden
edindi
belki
en güzel cümle
bu
ben de
Türkçe'de güzel
bir terminoloji
yaratmaya çalışıyorum
şöyle demek
daha doğru
mutex'i
kilitlemeden
edindi
ama bakın
burada ben
tam tersi
edinme fiilini
kullanmışım
mutex'i
kilitledi
şöyle daha güzel
evet
mutex'i kilitlediği
için
burada artık
g count'un
arttırılması
bir data
race
oluşturmayacak
burada mutex'i
serbest bıraktı
bazen serbest bıraktı
fiilini kullanıyorum
bazen
mutex'in
kilidini
açtı
artık ne
diyebiliriz ki
türkçede
evet
anlak karşılığı
ama
programın akışı
tekrar bu noktaya
geldiğinde
tekrar mutex'i
edindi
yine
mutex'i
mutex'in
kilidini
açtı
böylece
arada başka
kodlar olsa da
ben
unique lock
nesnesini
kullanarak
kodun içinde
farklı farklı
yerlerde
birden fazla
critical section
oluşturabiliyorum
ama güzel tarafı ne
diyelim ki
bu kod içinde
bakın
iki kere
lock
veya
etleme
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
sonraki kodu
görmüyoruz
ama diyelim ki
burada
bir daha
lock fonksiyonu
çağrılsaydı
bakın örnek
aslında çok güzel
burada bir daha
lock fonksiyonu
çağrılsaydı
evet
ve
g count
burada da
arttırılsaydı
takip edebiliyor muyuz
şimdi burada
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağırmamış
olsam dahi
kor döngüsünün
gövdesinin
sonunu oluşturan
closing price
scope'ın sonu
olduğu için
yine
kilit
unlock
edilecek
e şimdi
bakın
ne olması
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
iki tane
thread oluşturdum
böylece
üç tane
kritik bölge var
altı milyon mu
olması gerekiyor
sanırım
yaptığımız hesap
doğruysa
ve başka bir
problem yoksa
g count değişkeninin
değildiğinin
gördüğümüz gibi
altı milyon
olması gerekiyor
devam
yine
arkadaşlar
punk mutex'le
ilişkin
bir örnek
şöyle hızlı hızlı
örneklerimizi
geçelim
burada da
yine bir
unique
lock
nesnemiz var
fakat
arkadaşlar
kullandığı
mutex
tank mutex
kullandığı
mutex
tank mutex
olduğu için
interfazinde
try lock
for
fonksiyonu da var
yine
12.
satırda
mutex'i
edindi
artık
terminolojide
anlaştık
yani
mutex'e
bağlandı
ama
mutex'i
kilitlemedi
alttaki
if deyiminde
duration
kadar
sürede
kilitlemeye
çalışıyor
ben o duration'ı
5 mikrosaniye
yaptım
kilitlerse
standart
output'a
bu yazı
çıkacak
arkadaşlar
kilitleyemezse
bu yazı
çıkacak
ama
tabi burada
yine
ekran çıktısında
problem olabilir
çünkü
bu kod
kilit altında
çalışıyor
ama
buradaki kod
kilit altında
çalışmadığı için
burada
karakter bazında
çıkış
bozulabilir
o yüzden
burayı da
düzeltelim
en azından
o riski
almayalım
ve
osing stream
sınıfını
kullanalım
osing stream
c++
20 idi
temporary object'i
doğrudan
kullanabiliyorum
süper
şimdi
main fonksiyonunda
yine
constexper'e
bir değişkenim var
number of threads
bir
jthread vektörü
oluşturdum
number of threads'den
oluşan
burada
jthread'ler
default
construct edildi
ve
sonra
vektörü
dolaşıp
vektördeki
her bir
jthread'e
ne yapmış oldum
arkadaşlar
jthread nesnesini
taşımış oldum
bunu yazmak yerine
şöyle bir kod da
yazabilirdim
bu sefer
vektörü
default
construct ediyorum
bakın
kodu biraz daha farklı yazacağım
takip etmeye çalışın
evet
necad
şu anda
vektör boş
reserve fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
reallocation olmasın diye
oluşturacağım
thread sayısı kadar
jthread nesnesinin
yerini
baştan
rezerve ettim
ama şimdi
artık
vektör boş
vektöre
emplaceback
fonksiyonuyla
ne yapabilirim
arkadaşlar
eleman
ekleyebilirim
evet
emplaceback
bakın bu da çok öğretici bir örnek
şimdi emplaceback
vektörde tutulan
üenin
constructörüne
gönderilecek
argümanları
alıp
o argümanları
perfect forwarding
mekanizmasıyla
vektörün
constructörüne
argüman olarak
geçecek
dolayısıyla
ne geçmem
gerekiyor
jthread
nesnesini
arkadaşlar
jthread
nesnesini
özür dilerim
e
colobalı
yani
yukarıdaki
fonksiyon
f
bunun parametresine
geçilecek
argümanı
olmadığı için
doğrudan
f'i
argüman olarak
gönderebilirim
evet
şimdi
derleyelim
evet
bakalım
herhangi bir yazı
çıkmadı
peki
neden yazı çıkmadı
ona da bakalım
şimdi
şurada
esrakların
çağrılacağı
yeri de
belirleyelim
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bu fonksiyon
her bir
threadle
çağrıldığında
burada
kilide edinecek
edinirse
şu yazının
çıkması
lazım
edinemezse
bu yazının
çıkması
lazım
ama
herhalde
demin
yanlış bir şey
yaptık
bakalım
evet
siz de bakın
başka kodda
gördüğünüz eksik bir şey
var mı
evet
yani yazı
çıkıyor
sanırım
siliniyor
evet
şimdi
trial like
for
duration
mutex
kilitlendi
burada bir
problem yok
this thread
id
as
mutex
kilitlenemedi
new line
niye yazı
görmüyorum
söyleyin bakalım
bir yerde bir şeyi
kaçırmış olmalıyım
evet
and place
back
f
bu
j thread
vektörü
burada da bir problem
yok
reserve
number of
threads
and place
back
t
vek
aa
görüyor musunuz
arkadaşlar
kodu değiştirdim ya
burada ne yazmışım
burada önceki
koddan kalan
t
vek'in
size'ı var
ne alaka
ne olması
gerekiyor
şuradaki
döngüde
evet
number of threads
olması gerekiyor
işte kodu
değiştirince
burayı da değiştirmem
gerekiyordu
hata yine ben buldum
evet
anlaşıldı değil mi
yani bu kadar
thread'ı oluşturdum
derleyelim
şimdi çalışacak
başka bir eksik yoksa
bir önceki kodda
oluşturmuştu ki
evet bakın şimdi
mutex kilitlendi
hepsi kilitlemeye başardı
yani bu ne demek
buradaki
5 mikrosaniye
hepsi için
yeterli oldu
arkadaşlar
ama
5 mikrosaniyeyi
1 mikrosaniyeye
düşürelim
bakın 1 mikrosaniyeye
düşürdüğüm zaman
bir tanesi
kilidi
mutex'i kilitleyemedi
yetmedi
biraz daha
bunun da yarısını
alalım
1 mikrosaniyenin
yarısı
arkadaşlar
nedir
nanosaniyedir
değil mi
yanlış bir hesap
yapmıyorum
değil mi
nanosaniye
1 mikrosaniyenin
yarısı
nanosaniye
midir
evet
öyledir
değil mi
benim aritmetim
biraz zayıfladı
yaştan dolayı
bakın
nanosaniyeye
aldığımda
arkadaşlar
kilitlenememe
sayısı
arttı
daha da düşürelim
bu sefer
nanosaniye
olsun
evet
ve en son
ne yapalım
20 nanosaniyeye
kadar
çekelim
evet
peki
devam
yani görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
deterministik bir yapı
kesinlikle
söz konusu
değil
devam
bir de
time point ile
bir örnek yapmışım
onu da göstereyim
evet
arkadaşlar
burada ise
yine
unique
lag nesnesini
oluşturuyorum
ama
defer lag
argümanını
geçtiğim için
şöyle diyelim
kilitlemeden
edinildi
güzel bir
uyduruluk
bunu
kilitlemeden
edinildi
evet
ve
şu andaki
steady clock'ı
kullanarak
şu andaki
time point'ı
alıp
ona
bir
milisaniye
ekledim
ve bu sefer
trial lag for
fonksiyonu yerine
trial lag
until
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
zaten hep
bu çiftler
böyle değil mi
for olan
duration
istiyor
until
olan
time point
istiyor
şimdi bakın
edinme ve kilitleme
arasındaki farkı
çok güzel
gösteren bir örnek
arkadaşlar
bakın burada
mütex'i kilitledim
ama burada
sınıfın
release
fonksiyonu
mütex'i
unlock etmedi
sadece
mütex'in
mülkiyetini
bıraktı
tıpkı
nerede olduğu
gibi
akıllı
pointer
sınıflarımızda
olduğu gibi
ve
bize
sarmaladığı
mütex'in
adresini
döndürdü
yani burada
p-mutex
bir pointer
arkadaşlar
ama
tabi
eğer böyle bir
release fonksiyonuna
çağrı yapmışsam
bu şekilde
artık
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
benim görevim
yoksa
kilitli olarak
kalacak
değerliyip
çalıştırıyorum
evet
devam
şimdi gelelim
Scottlock'a
evet
arkadaşlar
bakınız
izleyin
Scottlock
yeni bir sınıf
kendi yerine göre
C++
17 ile
beklendi
azından
14 ve 17
mi ben de
karıştırıyorum
ama
C++
diyelim
yanlış olmasın
bakarız
arkadaşlar
Scottlock'ın
esprisi
neydi
lockart gibi
kullanılabiliyor
fakat
parametresi
konstruktörü
variadik parametreye
sahip
arkadaşlar
ve variadik parametreye
sahip olduğu için
birden fazla
mutex'i
konstruktörüne
argüman olarak
gönderebiliyorum
ve doğrudan
farklı sırada
lock etme
problemini
birden fazla kilidi
farklı sırada
lock edince
deadlock oluşuyordu ya
onu engellemek için
doğrudan
kullanabiliyorum
yani
scope lock
sınıfını
kullandığım zaman
global lock
fonksiyonunu
kullanmama
gerek kalmıyor
evet
şimdi bakalım
10. satırda
2 mutex'i birden
edindi
konstruktörü
ve ikisini de
kilitledi
sonra
100 milisaniye
trade'i
bloke ettik
sonra da
fung fonksiyonunu
arkadaşlar
burada
şöyle olmuş
foo fonksiyonunu
yazım hatası olmuş
çağrıldığını
yazdırım
aynısı
bar fonksiyonu
içinde de
yapıldı
böylece
sadece görmem
gereken
deadlock
oluşmadı
Mehmet Ali
Ekeci
edinilmek
sahiplik
bildiriyor
bence
unique lock
konstrukt edildi
ya da
konfigüre edildi
daha uygun
geliyor
değil
neden değil
Mehmet Ali
orayı belki
takip etmemiş
olabilirsiniz
bakın şimdi
konstrukt edilmesiyle
edinmek
aynı şey değil
mesela
soru
şimdi
ben
Mehmet Ali'ye
güzel bir cevap
vereyim
bakın şimdi
unique lock'ın
mutex
açılımı
my lock
şimdi sizin
terminolojiye
bakalım
my lock
nesnesi
konstrukt edildi
mi
cevap
tabii ki
çünkü
burada
my lock
nesnesi için
konstruktör çağrıldı
Mehmet Ali
öyle değil mi
şimdi
konstrukt edildi
ama
mutex edindi mi
hayır
herhangi bir
mutex edilmiş
durumda değil
ama nesneyi
böyle değil de
örneğin
şöyle oluştursaydım
arkadaşlar
öyle değil de
şöyle oluştursaydım
yine
konstrukt etmiş
olacaktım
fakat
mutex de
edinmiş olacaktı
burada
mutex de
edinmekten
kastım
elemanı olan
referansı
önceki derste
göstermiştim
ya ona
bağlaması
ama şimdi
bir başka örnek
daha
bakın
ikisi arasındaki
üç arasındaki
farka bakın
mtx
defer lock
şimdi aradaki
farka bakalım
konstrukt edildi
burada da
konstruksında
hiçbir problem yok
üçü de
konstrukt edildi
ama bir
mutex'e
bağlanmadı
yani bir
mutex'e
edinmedi
bir mutex'i
edindi
konstrukt edildi
ve bir mutex'i
edindi
ama o mutex'i
kilitledi
konstrukt edildi
bir mutex'i
edindi
ama o mutex'i
kilitlemedi
aradaki farkı
gördük mü
o yüzden
bir
terminoloji
oturtmakta
fayda var
evet
arkadaşlar
burada şimdi
scope lock'ın
bir özelliğini
daha göstereceğim
burada
a mutex ve
b mutex
aynı türden
ama
mesela
buradaki
b mutex
bir
recursive
mutex
olsaydı
bu kodda
yine
sentaks hatası
olmayacaktı
ya da
üçüncü bir
mutex'imiz
olsaydı
bu mutex de
timed
mutex
olsaydı
bu sefer
sadece legalite
açısından
bunun ismi de
c mutex
olsaydı
şimdi
lock guard
nesnesini
a mutex
b mutex
ve
c mutex
argümanlarıyla
çağırdığımda
bakın yine
az önce
tartıştığımız konuya
geri dönecek olursak
sadece
soruma cevap verin
şimdi
aradaki farkı
çok güzel göreceğiz
burada
guard isimli
nesne
konstrakt oldu mu
tabii
çünkü
konstraktları
çalıştı
mutex edindi mi
edindi
hem de
üç tane
mutex'i
birden edindi
üç tane
mutex'i
birden edinmesi
ne demek
aslında
üç tane
mutex'e de
bir referans
tutuyor
şimdi
bir mutex değil
üç mutex edindi
peki
üç mutex'i de
kilitledi mi
kilitledi
variadik
template olduğu
için
template
parametre paketinde
mutex'ler var
ama o mutex'lerin
aynı türden
olması
gerekmiyor
jenerik programlamaya da
yine
güzel bir örnek
arkadaşlar
evet
devam
biraz hızlanalım
haklımız iyice azaldı
evet
bakın
iki tane
mutex var
ve ben
scope lock
ile
iki mutex'i de
kilitlemeye
çalışıyorum
edindim
ve programın
akışı buraya
geldiğinde
kilitledim
sonra
elli milisaniye
bekledim
iki mutex'i de
release ettim
bar fonksiyonunda
yine
scope lock
kullandım
yine
iki mutex'i de
edinmeye
çalıştım
ve
farklı sırada
argümanları
geçmeme rağmen
deadlock
oluşmaması
konusunda
scope lock
bu garantiyi
veriyor
burada da
tema o
şimdi şu örneğe
bakın
bu da çok güzel
konuyu çok güzel
anlatan bir örnek
ama bu
derlemeyeceğim
sadece tahta olarak
kullanacağım
bakın şimdi
burada
swap isimli bir
fonksiyon var
bu da çok tipik
bir senaryo
nece burada
x ne
x herhangi bir sınıf
x is
any class
arkadaşlar
şimdi
swap fonksiyonu
buraya dikkat
x ve y
x ve
lhs ve
rhs parametrelerine
gelen
yani birinci ve ikinci
parametreye
referans semantiliyle gelen
arkadaşlar
x nesnelerine
swap edecek
takip edebiliyor muyuz
yani
aslında bu
swap fonksiyonu
iki tane
x nesnesine
swap ediyor
ama
buradaki
swap'ın
thread safe
olması için
mutex
kullanılıyor
ama bakın
kullanılan
mutexler de
sınıfların
veri elemanı
diyelim ki
m
değişkeni
aslında x isimli
sınıfın
mutex türünden
elemanı
ama şimdi burada
iki tane x nesnesinin
ikisinin de ayrı
mutex'i var
dolayısıyla bu
swap işleminin
yapılması için
her iki
nesnenin de
veri elemanı
olan mutex'in
lock fonksiyonunun
çağrılması
gerekiyor
işte bunun için
birinci yol
deadlock oluşmasın diye
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
lock fonksiyonuna
mutex nesnelerini
aldım
sonra
lockguard
nesnelerini
oluşturup
lockguard
sınıfının
konstruktörüne
adaptlock
geçtim
sonra da
buradaki
kodu çalıştırdım
swap işlemini
yapacaktım
ama
sonradan
stoplock
sınıfı
eklenince
C++
17 ile
diyelim
artık böyle bir
kod yazmama
gerek kalmadı
doğrudan
scoped lock
sınıfının
konstruktörüne
mutex nesnelerini
argüman olarak
geçiyorum
yani scoped lock
hangi sırada
argümanları
geçersek
geçelim
o mutex'leri
kilitleyecek
ama
arkadaşlar
kilitleme
gönderdiğim
argümanların
sırasının
bir önemi yok
ve deadlock
oluşmaması
garanti altında
şimdi
yavaş yavaş
artık
konunun
sonlarına
geliyoruz
arkadaşlar
bir de
daha sonradan
dile eklenen
shared mutex
sınıfı var
şöyle
bir
cpp
reference
dot com
dan da
göstereyim
ama
enteresan bir şekilde
geçen derste de
söylemiştim
sanırım
shared mutex'in
ayrı bir
başlık dosyası
var
yani
shared mutex
nerede değil
mutex
başlık dosyasında
değil
bunun da mutlaka
bir açıklaması
vardır ama
orayı
açıkçası
ilgilenmiyorum
ilgilenmedim
yani
diğer mutex
sınıfları ve
lock sınıfları
için
mutex
başlık dosyasını
dahil etmeniz
yeterli
ama
shared mutex
için
arkadaşlar
shared mutex
başlık dosyasını
dahil etmeniz
gerekiyor
şimdi burada
biraz
belki en karmaşık
yer bu
shared mutex
ve shared lock
sınıfı
önce
isimleri
birbirinden
ayıralım
shared mutex
mutex
sınıfının
ismi
ama
ben
shared mutex
sınıfı
türünden
nesneyi
sarmalayacak
bir
rayı
sınıfı
kullanmak
istersem
shared mutex
bazı
üye
fonksiyonlarına
map etmesi
için
kullanacağım
sınıfta
shared lock
sınıfı
yani
nasıl
arkadaşlar
unique lock
sınıfı
sarmalı
kendi
fonksiyonlarını
aslında
kendi
fonksiyonları
sarmaladığı
mutex
fonksiyonlarını
çağırıyorsa
shared lock
sınıfının
da
yine
üye fonksiyonları
sarmaladığı
shared mutex
sınıfının
arkadaşlar
üye fonksiyonlarını
çağırıyor
şimdi
burada
ana fikir ne
önce ondan bahsedelim
niye böyle bir sınıf var
arkadaşlar bu
multi thread
programlamada
bazen şöyle bir
tema oluyor
birden fazla
thread var
hatta
belki çok sayıda
diyelim ki
8 tane
16 tane
32 tane
thread var
fakat
threadlerden
bazıları
paylaşımlı
veriyi
yani
shared
source'u
arkadaşlar
salt
okuma amaçlı
kullanıyor
mesela diyelim ki
global bir değişken var
bu global değişkeni
çok sayıda
thread kullanacağı için
sizin bir
senkronizasyon
mekanizmasına
ihtiyacınız var
fakat o global
değişkeni
kullanacak
threadlerin
çok büyük
çoğunluğu
onu
okuma amaçla
erişiyor
e şimdi
diyeceksiniz ki
ne var
bunda
evet
bu durumda
şöyle bir
problem oluşuyor
problem
derken
bir verim
problemi
mesela
abartıyorum
16 tane
thread var
bu
threadlerden
bir tanesi
global değişkeni
set ediyor
ama diğer
15 thread
global
değişkeni
sadece
okuma amaçlı
kullanıyor
yani onun
değerini
kullanıyor
ama yine de
buradaki
15 thread'den
herhangi biri
mutex'i
kilitleyecek
değil mi
o veriyi
kullanmak için
ama bakın
mutex'i
o kilitlede
ama başka bir
thread yine
okuma amaçlı
o değişkeni
kullandığında
o da
aynı mutex'i
kilitliyor
bu durumda
hepsi aslında
okuma amaçlı
erişmesine rağmen
yani
sadece
biri yazma amaçlı
erişmesine rağmen
geriye kalan
15 tanesi
yine adeta
buyrukta
bekleyecek
kilidin açılması
için
şimdi buradaki
fikir ne
shared mutex
buraya dikkat
buradan sonrasın
biraz daha dikkatli
dinlememiz gerekiyor
shared mutex
iki ayrı
kilitleme
olanağı
veriyor
bir kilitleme
ekskluzif
kilitleme
öyle deniyor
İngilizce'de
arkadaşlar
yani ekskluzif
kilitleme
right
amaçlı kilitleme
demek
bir de
ekskluzif
olmayan
shared
kilitleme
var
yani siz
mutex'i
ekskluzif
olarak
ya da
shared
olarak
kilitlemeniz
onu
yazma amaçlı
ya da
okuma amaçlı
kullanacağınızı
belirliyor
şimdi yavaş yavaş
gidelim
biraz karmaşık
eğer
herhangi bir
thread
mutex'i
shared mutex'i
ekskluzif
olarak
kilitlerse
arkadaşlar
sadece tek bir
mutex
bunu kilitleyebilir
tek bir thread
sadece tek bir thread
kritik bölgeye
girebilir
ama
buraya dikkat
eğer
mutex'i
paylaşımlı olarak
bir thread
kilitlerse
bu durumda
paylaşımlı olarak
kilitlendiği zaman
artık
ekskluzif
kilitlemek için
o
bir thread
o mutex'i
beklemek zorunda
ama
okuma amaçlı
threadler
beklemek zorunda
değil
yani siz
yazma amaçlı
kilitlediğiniz zaman
sadece
o yazma amaçlı
thread
kritik bölgeye
giriyor
okuma amaçlı
kilitleyebilmeniz
için
yazma amaçlı
kilitlenmemiş
olması gerekiyor
ama orada
okuma amaçlı
bütün threadler
kritik bölgeye
girebiliyor
böylece
okuma işlemlerinin
sayısı
arkadaşlar
çok daha
fazla ise
o zaman
okuyacak
threadler
boş yere
ne yapmıyor
beklemek zorunda
blok olmak zorunda
kalmıyor
şimdi burada
özetlersek
arkadaşlar
paylaşımlı
kilitlemede
birden fazla
thread
mutex'i
kilitleyebiliyor
bu da ne demek
birden fazla
thread
kritik bölgeye
girebiliyor
ama okuma amaçlı
arkadaşlar
ama yazma amaçlı
thread
yazma amaçlı
kilitlenirse
artık
diğer bütün
threadler
ister okuma amaçlı
olsun
ister yazma amaçlı
beklemek zorunda
kritik bölgeye
girmek için
evet
hemen
şöyle bir
interfejsi de
göstermek istiyorum
burası gerçekten
diğerlerine göre
biraz karmaşık
hadi bakalım
buradan
şimdi hızlı bir şekilde
takip edelim
a shared mutex
aynı zamanda buna
multiple reader
single writer
mutex de
deniyor
demiş
eksklusif amaçlı
yani yazma amaçlı
ve paylaşımlı
okuma amaçlı
kilitlemeye
izin veriyor
iki tür
kilidi var
biri eksklusif
kilit
işte bu yazma amaçlı
olan
diğeri de
shared
kilit
paylaşımlı olan
şimdi diyeceksiniz ki
Necati
peki nasıl bunu yapacağım
ya son derece basit
fonksiyonların
isimleri farklı
buraya dikkat
fonksiyonların
isimleri farklı
eğer
eksklusif olarak
kilitlerseniz
sadece
bir thread
mutex'i
kilitli olarak
tutabiliyor
arkadaşlar ve
bir mutex
onu kilitlemişken
ister okuma amaçlı
ister yazma amaçlı
hiçbir thread
kritik bölgeye
giremiyor ama
shared
lock
olursa
yani
paylaşımlı
kilitlerseniz
bu durumda
istediği kadar
istenilen sayıda
thread
oraya
okuma amaçlı
kilitleyebiliyor
ve kritik bölgeye
girebiliyor
arkadaşlar
bakın burada
açık açık
benim söylediğimi
yazmış
diyor ki
a shared mutex
would typically
be used
to protect
shared data
that is seldom
updated
nadiren
seyrek bir şekilde
set edilen
update edilen
ama
arkadaşlar
okuma
miktarı
daha fazla
olduğu zaman
tercih edilebilir
diyor
evet
şimdi
interfazine de
bir bakalım
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
iki farklı
interfaz var
biri
shared kilitleme
için
bu arada
Rasul bir şey
yazmış
birkaç
serbest bir
database'den
aynı infoları
okumak için
kullanılabilir
evet kesinlikle
mesela zaten
verilen
çok güzel
Rasul
zaten verilen
tipik örnekler
bakın hangi kitaba
cppreference.com
vesaire
nereye
baksanız
ilk verilen örnek
database örneği
yani database'den
okuma işlemi
database'de bir
update işleminden
tipik olarak
çok daha fazla
şimdi
bu fonksiyonlar
ismi
lock olan
try lock olan
yani
diğer
ray sınıflarındaki
o klasik
isimler
burada
ekskluzif
olana
kilitlemeye
karşılık geliyor
yani örneğin
ben
mutex'in
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
ekskluzif
olarak
kilitliyorum
lock
kilitlerse
başka hiç kimse
kritik bölüğe
giremez
aynı şekilde
try lock
eğer kilitlerse
ekskluzif
olarak
kilitlemiş
olacak
söylemeye
gerek yok
ama bakın
bir de
içinde
shared
geçen
lock
fonksiyonları
var
lock shared
try lock
shared
shared for
try lock
shared
until
ve unlock
shared
şimdi burada
önemli bir nokta
daha
bu fonksiyonlar
mutex'in
fonksiyonları
dolayısıyla
ben
ya bir
rayi nesnesi
kullanmayacağım
o da çok
tehlikeli
exception
and link
de
exception
safe
olmayacak
ya da
buraya dikkat
burası önemli
ya da
bir ne
kullanacağım
bir rayi
sınıfı
kullanacağım
yalnız
burada
işte
kritik noktada
burası
eğer
eksklusif olarak
kullanacaksam
kilidi
eksklusif olarak
kilitleyeceksem
rayi sınıfının
örneğin
lock card
scope card
scope lock
ya da
unique lock
olmasında
bir sakınca yok
çünkü
onlar
zaten
şu fonksiyonları
veriyorlar
değil mi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
yani
sınıfın ne olduğuna
bağlı olarak
ama
aylaşımlı taraf için
yine bir
rayi nesnesine
ihtiyacımız olursa
onun
ne olması
gerekiyor
shared lock
rayi sınıfı
olması gerekiyor
işte
zaten
en başta
rayi sınıflarınızı
herkence öyle
demiştik ya
lock card
unique lock
scope lock
ve shared lock
mutex sınıflarında
saymıştık
işte orada
en son eklenen
mutex sınıfı da
şunlardı
bütün hepsini
şimdi sayarsak
mutex
recursive mutex
time mutex
recursive time mutex
shared mutex
bir de
shared mutex'in
yine nesi var
time shared mutex'i var
arkadaşlar
zaten alışınca
interfezini de
tahmin edebiliyorsunuz
tahmin etmezseniz de
zaten işte
idede
hangi fonksiyonları
olduğunu
görürsünüz
evet
şimdi
şurayı
özellikle
ben yazdım
yanlış anlaşılmayı
da engellemek
için
biraz bekleteceğim
şuraya şöyle bir
not ekleyeyim
bakın
şimdi bir
eksklusif
thread
bir thread
belki cümle
biraz daha
üzgün olmalı
bir thread
kilidi
eksklusif
olarak edindiğinde
burada edinmek
yerine
kilitlediğinde
başımızın belası
terminoloji
a
o thread
kritik bölgeye
girmiş olur
bu durumda
reader threadler
kritik bölgeye
giremez
writer threadler
yine
kilitleyemez
arkadaşlar
bunların
olabilmesi için
writer threadin
kilidi serbest
bırakması
yani
anlat etmesi
gerekir
writer threadin
kilidi bırakmış
olması
kritik bölgeyi
terk etmiş
olduğu anlamına
gelir
reader threadlere
gelince
kilidi
elinde
bulunduran
bir eksklusif
thread
kilidini
bırakana kadar
yani kilidi
anlat edene
kadar
herhangi bir
reader thread
kilidi
edinemez
bir reader thread
kilidi
paylaşımlı
olarak edinmişse
arkadaşlar
bir reader thread
kilidi
paylaşımlı
olarak
evde edinmişse
eksklusif
thread
artık
kritik bölgeyi
terk etmiş demektir
yoksa
edinemezdik
zaten
yani ona
güvenerek
kodu
yazabiliriz
bir reader thread
kilidi
paylaşımlı
olarak edinmişse
diğer reader
threadler
threadlerde
paylaşımlı
olarak
aynı
kilidi
kilitleyebilir
kullanabilir
evet
reader threadlerden
biri
kilidi
kilitlediğinde
kritik bölgeye
girmiş olur
diğer tüm
reader threadler
de yine
kilidi
kullanabilir
yani
onlar için de
artık
kilitli
durumda
onların
threadde
ve data
reyesi
oluşacak
bir senaryo
söz konusu
değil
reader ve
writer threadler
bir arada
kritik bölgede
olamazlar
birden fazla
writer thread
yine bir arada
kritik bölgede
olamaz
arkadaşlar
ama birden fazla
reader thread
kritik bölgede
olabilir
ama tabi
shared mutex'inde
ilave bir maliyeti
var
mesela mutex'e göre
arkadaşlar
daha yavaş
daha fazla
bellek alanı
kullanıyor
evet
şimdi tekrar
buraya geri dönelim
son olarak
üye fonksiyonlarını
gördük
arkadaşlar
bir tane de
örnek yapalım
bu konuyu da
artık
bu mutex ve
lock
nesnelerimiz
konusunda
burada
kapatalım
ve yavaş yavaş
nereye geleceğiz
condition
variable
konusuna
geleceğiz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
shared mutex'le
bir örneği
oluşturmak
çok kolay değil
şu nedenle
kolay değil
yanlış anlaşılmasın
hani basit
sadece
sentax'ı
ya da sınıfın
nasıl çalıştığını
göstermeye yönelik
örneklere
biraz espri ve
şekilde
toy example
deniyor
yani
üretimde
kullanılan
bir kod
değil
ama
açıklamaya yönelik
bir kod
ama
gerçek bir tema
olmadığı zaman
toy example'lar bile
yeterince açıklayıcı olmuyor
o yüzden
ben yine bir kod yazdım ama
o kodun üstünden
birlikte geçelim
yani herhangi bir şekilde
bir hata olduğunu
düşünürseniz
siz yine bana
söyleyin
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakınız
bir
shared mutex
nesnem var
şimdi
soru bir
mutex'in
shared mutex
olması
bu mutex'i
edinecek
rayı sınıfının da
shared lock
olmasını
zorunlu kılmıyor
ama
shared lock
olmazsa
yani
bu mutex'i
edinecek
rayı sınıf nesnesi
shared lock
türünden olmazsa
az önce
interfeiste
gördüğümüz
içinde
shared geçen
fonksiyonları
çağırma şansı
yok
anlaşıldı
anlaşıldı mı
ama zaten
o fonksiyonları
çağırmayacaksam
sadece
eksklusif
olarak
fonksiyonları
kullanacaksam
kilitleyeceksem
o zaman
sarmalayıcı
sınıfın
shared lock
olması
gerekmiyor
evet
zaten örnekte
göstereceğim
bakın zaten
örnek bunu
gayet güzel gösteriyor
bir şey dikkatinizi
çekiyor mu
burada
lock nesnesi
scope lock
takip edebiliyor muyuz
ama
sarmaladığı
mutex
edindiği mutex
shared mutex
peki
neden
scope lock'ı
kullandım
e çünkü
sadece
burada
benim rayı
nesnem
edindiği mutex'in
lock ve
unlock
fonksiyonlarını
çağırdı
shared mutex'in
lock ve
unlock
fonksiyonları
zaten
ekskluzif
olarak
kilitleyen
fonksiyonlar
dolayısıyla
writer thread
buraya girdiğinde
arkadaşlar
herhangi bir
writer thread
bu writer
fonksiyonunu
çalıştırdığında
10 kez
bu döngüde
döngü değişkeni
özür dilerim
count
global değişken
yani paylaşımı
kullanan değişken
10 kez
arttırılacak
ama
tabi ki
burada
artık
arkadaşlar
count değişkenine
yani bu fonksiyondaki
bu kritik bölgeye
kim giremez
başka bir
writer
giremez
başka bir
reader
giremez
arkadaşlar
döngünler
turunda
biraz zaman
geçsin diye
milisaniyede
bekletiyorum
neden
milisaniye
bekletiyorum
tahmin edebiliyorsunuz
değil mi
o 100
milisaniye
zaman
dilimi
içinde
okuma amaçlı
threadlerden
biri ya da
birden fazlası
bu kilidi
serbest bıraktığında
arkadaşlar
ne yapabilsin diye
okuma amaçlı
ona erişebilsin diye
şimdi de
reader'a bakalım
arkadaşlar bu arada
reader'ın
ikinci
parametresine
referans
semantiğiyle
bir
off stream
nesnesini
göndereceğim
neden
çünkü
ekran çıktısı
ekranda çok fazla
standart altında
çok fazla bir şey
yazıldığı zaman
hepsini görmen
mümkün olmuyor
çok ayıp gidiyor ya
o yüzden
dosyaya yazdırmasını
istiyorum
böylece bakın
şurası da
önemli
main fonksiyonu
içinde
yazma amaçlı
bir dosya
oluşturdum
işte
out.txt
isimli
yine bir
jthread
vektörü
oluşturuyorum
ve
arkadaşlar
önce
bir tane
writer thread
ekledim
ama
arkadaşlar
15 tane de
16 olmasın
15 olsun
15 tane de
reader thread
ekledim
hepsi
aynı vektörde
dolayısıyla
bütün
bu threadler
koşmaya
başlıyor
vektördeki
writer thread
writer
fonksiyonunu
çalıştıracak
vektörde
geriye kalan
diğer
15 thread
arkadaşlar
neyi çalıştıracak
reader fonksiyonunu
çalıştıracak
ama bir şeye bakın
yine daha önce
öğrendiklerimiz için
iyi bir örnek
arkadaşlar
şimdi ben
çalışan bütün
threadlerin
aynı dosyayı
kullanmasını
istiyorum
işte kullanmasını
istediğim dosyada
burada
ismi
out.txt
olan dosya
ama
fonksiyonun
parametresi
referans olduğu için
referans
semantiğiyle
bu
söz konusu
thread
bu fonksiyonu
çalıştırırken
aldığı argümanı
c-thread
nesnesi
referans
semantiğiyle
geçsin diye
görüyorsunuz
reference
wrapper
sınıfını
kullandım
şimdi
buradan
olacak
burası
kritik yer
şimdi bu noktaya
geldiğimizde
takip edin
aslında
16 tane
thread
birlikte
koşmaya
başladı
yani 15 tane
thread
reader
fonksiyonunu
çalıştırıyor
bir tane
thread
writer
fonksiyonunu
çalıştırıyor
şimdi
writer
fonksiyonuna
baktık
arkadaşlar
ne yapıyordu
döngünler
turunda
kilidi
mutex'i
kilitledi
ve sayacı
arttırdı
ama
döngünün bir sonraki
turuna geçmeden de
100 milisaniye
bekledi
şimdi
reader
fonksiyonuna
bakalım
reader fonksiyonunda ise
100 kez dönen bir döngü var
döngünün her turunda
şuradaki nested blok içinde
bir shared lock nesnesi oluşturdum
şimdi burada
shared lock
ray sınıfını
kullanmak
zorundayım
çünkü neden
arkadaşlar
bu sınıf
o
örneğin shared lock
nesnesi destroy olduğunda
mutex'in
unlock fonksiyonunu
değil
unlock shared
fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
evet
ve
bu global count
değişkeninin
değerini
yerel değişken
c'ye aktardım
böylece
okuma amaçlı
erişmiş oldum
ama
hangi thread
olursa olsun
burada
eş zamanlı
olarak
eğer yazma amaçlı
thread
mutex'i kilitlememişse
bunların her biri
edinebilir
burada da
döngünler turunda
dosyaya
hem thread'in
id'sini
yani reader
thread'lerden hangisi ise
onun id'sini
yazdırdım
hem de
count değişkeninin
değerini
yazdırdım
yani okunmuş
count değişkeninin
değerini yazdırdım
ve 10 milisaniye
bekledim
arkadaşlar
burada
o zaman
şunu göreceksiniz
değiştirme işlemi
arada bir yapılıyor
set işlemi
ama okuyan
thread'ler
buraya geldiğinde
kilidi edindikleri anda
bu değeri
okuyabilecekler
burada şunu da
görmemiz lazım
değil mi
birden fazla
thread'in
okuma amaçlı
kullandığını
gösterecek
bir emarede
ne
sıradaki
c değeri
dosyaya yazılan
o her satırda
birden fazla
aynı değer olabilir
hadi bakalım
koşturalım
evet
şimdi
a
tx
dosyasına
bakalım
arkadaşlar
bakın
şimdi
bir
no'lu
thread
yani
benim verdiğim
id bu
sıfır
değerini
okumuş
iki
thread
idli thread
sıfır
değerini
okumuş
sıfır
idli thread
yine
sıfır
değerini
okumuş
sonra
üç
girmiş
o da
sıfır
değerini
okumuş
takip edebiliyorsunuz
değil mi
bu arada
demek ki
writer thread
girdi ki
sıfırdan
bire çekti
ama
writer thread
bunu bir
yaptığında
bizim
okuyan
thread'lerden
bakın
o döngüde
on iki
şuraya
kadar
hep
okuma
amaçlı
biri
okumuş
der
bu arada
tekrar
writer thread
iki
yapmış
arkadaşlar
bakın
burada
yine
deterministik
değil
burada
iki
olmasına
rağmen
bu yazı
o yazıdan
daha önce
çıkmış
ama
aslında
iki
yapıldıktan
sonra
bunlar
iki
olarak
okuyor
bakın
bu arada
şunu da
gösteriyor
bu
standart
output'a
yazma
sırası
deterministik
mesela şu anda
bazı thread'ler
iki olarak
okuyor
bazı thread'ler
bir olarak
okuyor
ama
buraya
yazma
sırası
değişiyor
sırasıyla
özetle bakın
iki oldu
üç oldu
dört oldu
beş oldu
altı oldu
böyle gidiyor
şimdi buradaki
parametrelerle
biraz oynasam
mesela bir
düşünelim
ne yapalım
bu
yüz milisaniye
uyumak yerine
yirmi
milisaniye
uyusa
arkadaşlar
evet
ve
tam tersi
bu
yüz milisaniye
uyusa
bakalım
görüntü ne olacak
bu durumda
bir dakika
yüz milisaniye
o kadar
büyük bir değer ki
bu bitmez
zaten
şöyle diyelim
bu
bir milisaniye
beklesin
bunlar da
arkadaşlar
beş yüz
nanosaniye
beklesin
evet
en azından
şimdi
bu kadar
uzun
sürmeyecek
bakalım
alt nokta
tx
t y
şimdi bakın
durum tamamen
değişti
sıfırda
yakalamış
bunlar
bir değerinde
yakalamış
bazıları
iki değerinde
yakalamış
bazıları
dört değerinde
yakalamış
evet
burada
sadece
neyi
göstermiş
olduk
arkadaşlar
çok thread
okuma
amaçla
erişiyor
bazı threadler
yazma
amaçla
erişiyor
Resul
Mehmetov
diyor ki
iki ve birin
karışması
yirmi sekizinci
satırdaki
int c'den
olabilir mi
evet
arkadaşlar
zaten bakın
son konularımız
bununla ilgili
olacak
şimdi
ordering
single thread
çalıştığında
çok açık
kurallara
bağlı
yani
mesela
siz şöyle bir
kod yazsanız
artı artı x
arkadaşlar
burada da
x'i
kullanan
bir başka
ifade
yazsanız
şimdi
bu single thread
çalıştığında
son derece
basit
bu kodun
semantik
anlamını
derleyici
değiştiremez
mesela derleyici
burada
reordering
yapamaz
öyle değil mi
ama bakın
burada
alttaki
statement'ın
x'in
artmış
değerini
kullanması
garanti altında
ya
ama
multi thread
tarafta
dünyası
tamamen
farklı
yani
eğer siz
şunu sağlamak
istiyorsanız
efendim
x değişkeni
değeri
arttıktan
sonra
falanca
thread
bunu
okusun
işte
onu
sağlamak
için
araçlar
kullanmak
zorundasınız
yani
iki ayrı
thread
onu
doğrudan
senkronize
etme
şansınız
yok
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi o zaman
bugünkü dersin sonunda
bu
mutexleri
ve rayı
sınıflarını
bitirmiş olduk
ilk başlığımızı
dağıtalım
nerede
kaldığımızı
anlamak
için
condition
variable
ve bir
giriş de
yapalım
yani
condition
variable
ne işe
yarıyor
aslında
en önemli
araçlardan
biri
arkadaşlar
şimdi biz
threadleri
kullanmaya
başladık
ama
daha ortada
bir sürü
soru var
mesela
halen
bir thread
bir
horrible
koşturduğunda
onun
geri dönüş
değerini
nasıl
iletecek
bu soru
halen
cevapsız
kaldı
bu bir
fakat
daha önemli
bir soru
var
arkadaşlar
bu
multi-thread
programlamada
en çok
ihtiyaç duyulan
araçlardan
biri
çalışan
threadlerden
biri
bir
thread
arkadaşlar
bir işlemi
gerçekleştirdikten
sonra
bu işlem
herhangi bir işlem
olabilir
örneğin bir
değişkeni
set etme
olabilir
bir işlemi
gerçekleştirdikten
sonra
bu işlemin
gerçekleştirilmesini
bekleyen
bir thread'in
bundan
haberi
olacak
ve artık
bu işlem
gerçekleştikten
sonra
diğer thread
o kodu
çalıştıracak
mesela
arkadaşlar
tipik
bu
üretici
tüketici
problemi
bir thread
veriyi
hazırlıyor
data'yı
provide ediyor
ama başka
bir thread
de
o thread'in
ürettiği
veriyi
kullanıyor
dolayısıyla
veriyi
kullanabilmesi
için
diğer thread'in
veriyi
üretmiş
olduğundan
emin
olmamız
gerekiyor
dolayısıyla
bir thread'in
bir thread'i
beklemesi
gerekiyor
bütün problem
bu
yani
ben örneğin
bir thread'im
arkadaşlar
user
bir fonksiyon
olduğumu
düşünün
burada
bir işlemi
yapabilmem
için
başka bir
thread'in
bir işlemi
yapmasını
bitirmesini
yapmayı
bekliyorum
şimdi burada
diyeceksiniz ki
nasıl bunu
bekleyebilirim
güvenli bir şekilde
ilk aklımıza
gelen şu
olabilir
bir tane
global
değişken
alırım
o global
değişkeni
bu
datayı
örneğin
provide eden
sağlayan
thread
set eder
boolean
bir flag
olduğunu
düşünün
ama
bu thread'de
o boolean
değişkenin
değerinin
true olup
olmadığını
sürekli
örneğin
kontrol
eder
buna yönelik
bir
senkronizasyon
mekanizması
oluşturabilirim
ama
burada da
problem ne
işte
bir dahaki
dersimiz çok
önemli
o yüzden
arkadaşlar
diğer
thread'in
o işlem yapılana
kadar
işlemci zamanını
harcamamasını da
istiyoruz
yani
eğer siz
sürekli
kontrol ederseniz
buna
İngilizce'de
polling deniyor
sürekli
bakıyorum
veri hazır mı
ama bunun için
bir kod çalışıyor
işlemci zamanını
alıyor
şimdi
öyle bir
sistem olsun ki
bizim
thread'imiz
yani bir işlemin
gerçekleşmesini
bekleyen
thread
arkadaşlar
blokü
olsun
ama işlemi
gerçekleştiren
thread
adeta
ona bir
sinyal göndersin
ben işlemi
bitirdim
diye
o zaman
uyansın
ama o işlem
yapılana
kadar
o veri
üretilene
kadar
blokü
olarak
kalsın
böylece
işlemci zamanını
da
boş yere
harcamasın
işte bu amaçla
kullanılan
genel
primitif
senkronizasyon
araçlarından biri
bizim
bu
condition
variable
sınıfımız
arkadaşlar bakın
son olarak
bir
analojiden
bahsedeyim
çok
bu konuyu
anlatmak için
bu
Anthony Williams'ın
kitabında
meşhur
bu
concurrency
in action
kitabında
kullandığı
analoji
ben de
şimdi
Eskişehir'de
oturduğum için
Ankara'dan
ve
İstanbul'dan
trenle
geliniyor
hızlı tren
var
örnek
bana da
uyuyor
şimdi ben
trene bindim
diyelim ki
İstanbul'dan
ama
Eskişehir'de
ineceğim
çok da
uykum var
arkadaşlar
ama
istasyonu da
kaçırmak
istemiyorum
çünkü
Eskişehir
istasyonunda
inmezsem
soluğu artık
Polatlı'da
Ankara'da
falan alacağım
dolayısıyla
tren istasyona
geldiğinde
benim bundan
haberim olması
lazım ki
arkadaşlar
evet
ama şimdi
sürekli uyursam da
uyurken
istasyonu
kaçırmış olurum
ama
eğer uyumazsam da
uykusuz kalacağım
geldi mi
hayır daha var
ama şimdi
şöyle bir şey olsa
ben uyusam
ama oradaki
bir görevli
trende görevliler
olur ya
kondüktör mü
deniyordu
oradaki görevli
zaten öyle bir
anonsta
yapıyorlar
genelde
benim
Eskişehir'de
ineceğimi
bildiği için
ben uyuyorum
ama
tren Eskişehir'e
gelince
geliyor
beni uyandırıyor
tren Eskişehir'e
geldi diye
böylece ben
uykusuz kalmadım
uyudum
ama
treni de
kaçırma
istasyonu
kaçırma riskini de
almamış oldum
işte
Condition Variable'da
böyle
yani
Bitred
diyor ki
madem beni
bekliyorsunuz
siz uyuyun
ben
işimi
bitirdiğim zaman
sizi
uyandıracağım
siz uyandığınız zaman
artık
işim
bittiğinden
emin olacak
ve o işin
gerçekleşmiş
işin
sonuçlarını
kullanabilecek
durumda
olacaksınız
evet
peki
bir dahaki hafta
pazartesi günü
ilk dersimiz
Condition Variable
ondan sonra da
artık
arkadaşlar
Future Promise
Async fonksiyonu
yani
threadlerin
koşturduğu fonksiyonların
geri dönüş değerlerinin
kullanılması
bu konulara
bakacağız
derse katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
bir dahaki hafta
pazartesi günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
görmek üzere
abone ol